Hey guys, it's Joel, and this is part two of Empire, Oil, and the Odyssey, which is a jumping off, you know, continuing from the psychohistory series that we just did talking about how these bureaucracies are sort of a part of psychology at a micro level in the individual, but also a macro level in the society. And so I'm not just picking on academic psychology and the cold machine, you know, of the bureaucracy around academic psychology and psychology research. I think a lot of that silliness is not just something that psychologists do. It's something that is an academic researchers do. It's just something that's kind of a human thing. But one thing that I wanted to say before we get into part two, because I forgot from last time, I'd written it down and then I started talking and talked over it. Somebody wrote an email and said, why if the FDA presented this in 2024, this rejection of accepting the MDMA study is moving forward?
大家好，我是乔尔。这是《帝国、石油与奥德赛》的第二部分。我们接着上一期关于心理历史学的系列内容继续探讨，即这些官僚机构如何在个体层面作为心理的一部分，同时又在社会层面作为宏观结构存在。我并不是专门针对学术心理学，或者学术心理学和心理学研究周围那套冷冰冰的官僚机器。我认为很多荒谬之处不仅仅是心理学家的问题，而是所有学术研究者的问题，这更像是一种人类的通病。但在进入第二部分之前，我想补充一点，因为上次我写下来了，结果说得太投入给忘了。有人发邮件问，如果FDA在2024年就提出了这个拒绝接受MDMA研究的决定，为什么这件事还在推进？
Why is it in the news in 2026, which is a good question? Um, the reason is that, uh, Trump signed basically an executive order saying that they needed to expedite that and do it faster. Um, and Biden did a similar thing with psilocybin when Biden was in office because this is one of the cheaper things that they can do when you want to be like, oh, we're in a mental health crisis. Like I really like the poor people that are traumatized or I really like the troops that are traumatized in the VA and like it's not working. Um, generally like one of the fastest things that you can do is tell somebody that there's like a miracle drug on the horizon that is coming. You know, like I don't know how much good faith you want to ascribe to
为什么到了2026年它还在新闻里？这是一个好问题。嗯，原因是特朗普签署了一项行政命令，基本上要求他们加快进度，做得更快。嗯，拜登在任时对裸盖菇素也做了类似的事情，因为当你想要表现出“哦，我们正处于心理健康危机中”时，这是他们能做的成本最低的事情之一。就像我真的很关心那些受创伤的穷人，或者我真的很关心退伍军人事务部里那些受创伤的士兵，但实际上并没有什么效果。嗯，通常来说，你能做的最快的事情之一就是告诉某人，地平线上有一款奇迹药物即将到来。你知道，我不知道你愿意对这些事情抱有多少善意。
any of these things, even if they're doing something that, like, I don't think Trump is doing this for the, or Biden is doing this for the reason that I was saying that the FDA should have in the first episode. I think it's a similar thing that, you know, what Biden did with psilocybin was said, I'm going to put a whole bunch of money forward for research into psilocybin so that a private company can get it and and patent it, some form that we know is, uh, you know, there's not a lot of liability around and can pass regulations and that because this is some miracle drug that needs to happen on horizon. Um, generally like I'm kind of suspect of that stuff because what happens with the things like especially psilocybin is they say, okay, uh, this is a naturally occurring
即使他们做了一些事情，比如，我不认为特朗普或拜登做这些事的原因是我在第一集里说的FDA应该有的那种原因。我认为这是一回事，你知道，拜登对裸盖菇素所做的是说，我要投入一大笔钱用于裸盖菇素的研究，这样一家私营公司就可以获得它并申请专利，以某种我们知道的、你知道的、没什么责任风险的形式，并且可以通过法规，因为这是一种需要在地平线上出现的奇迹药物。嗯，总的来说，我对这些东西持怀疑态度，因为像裸盖菇素这类东西发生的情况是，他们会说，好吧，这是一种天然存在的
thing that we can't really patent. So in order for a private company to care enough to, uh, do anything with it, they would have to find some way to package it to where it is patentable, which generally means you like mix it with a salt. And then you say like when this thing is mixed with baking soda, you know, and you know, IV saline, it all of a sudden is its own drug and then we can patent it. And so now this company will do it. And another thing that they do is something called like a Rasmur or a polymorph, if you remember chemistry, which is really silly. It's a really silly part of how the U.S. allows drug companies to patent drugs. It basically means you have the exact same molecule, but it's a slightly different shape.
东西，我们真的无法申请专利。所以为了让一家私营公司有足够的兴趣去利用它做点什么，他们必须找到某种方法将其包装成可申请专利的形式，这通常意味着你把它和盐混合。然后你说，当这东西和烘焙苏打，你知道，还有静脉注射生理盐水混合时，它突然就成了它自己的一种药物，然后我们就可以申请专利了。于是现在这家公司就会去做这件事。他们做的另一件事叫做外消旋体或多晶型物，如果你还记得化学的话，这真的很荒谬。这是美国允许制药公司为药物申请专利的方式中非常荒谬的一部分。它基本上意味着你拥有完全相同的分子，但形状略有不同。
So if you remember chemistry, like unless something's like a fat or a fairly complicated molecule, it doesn't really matter as long as you've got the same amount of atoms of the same type, what shape it's in. So like, for example, you might have something that is a molecule or it's an atom that can bind to something in five different spots. well, if you have the same amount of things binding to it, like if you have two things bound to it, it doesn't really matter where they attach. As long as they're on one of those five spots
所以如果你还记得化学，除非是脂肪或相当复杂的分子，否则只要你拥有相同类型的原子数量，它是什么形状其实并不重要。所以，例如，你可能有一种分子或原子，它可以在五个不同的点上与某物结合。好吧，如果你有相同数量的东西与它结合，比如你有两个东西与它结合，它们附着在哪里其实并不重要。只要它们在其中的五个点上就行。
for a simple molecule that might do something with dopamine, it's the same thing. And so a different shape of the same molecule is called a Rasmer. Like one of the things nexium, like prylaseum is basically one, the L shape of the nexium rasmor of which there are three. I think. Maybe there's two. I don't really remember. It's been a long time since my psychoform classes.
对于一个可能与多巴胺发生作用的简单分子来说，情况也是一样的。所以同一个分子的不同形状被称为外消旋体。就像耐信（Nexium）一样，比如普利赛克（Prilosec）基本上就是耐信外消旋体中的一种L型，我想有三种。也许有两种。我真的不记得了。距离我的药物化学课已经过去很久了。
But anyway, it's a silly thing where what happens generally when the government does this, like what Biden did is gave a bunch of money to private companies to research psilocybin. But if they did patent something, which they haven't yet, and they got it through trials, which they haven't yet, they would own it. And then it would just become really expensive again because all of that taxpayer money that's like your money and my money would just go to the bottom line of a company that now owns this thing. It can charge whatever they want for it. Doesn't seem like a great system. Also, what Trump's doing is just telling the FDA to, like, expedite the process and make it go through faster so that they can research MDMA.
但无论如何，这是一件荒谬的事情，当政府这样做时，通常会发生什么，就像拜登所做的那样，给了私营公司一大笔钱去研究裸盖菇素。但如果他们真的申请了专利（虽然他们还没申请），并且通过了试验（虽然他们还没通过），他们就会拥有它。然后它又会变得非常昂贵，因为所有那些纳税人的钱，也就是你的钱和我的钱，最终都会流向一家现在拥有这个东西的公司的底线。他们可以随意定价。这看起来不是一个很好的系统。此外，特朗普所做的只是告诉FDA加快流程，让它通过得更快，以便他们可以研究MDMA。
But what's kind of silly about that is, like, that isn't saying what the problem is with the system. And then that, like, it should be different. It's just being like, I'm going to kind of put my hand on the scale because we need something to happen here. So anyway, people ask about why this 2024 study was relevant in 26. I meant to say it and I completely forgot to do it. One of the things is kind of funny, more on this later, sorry,
但荒谬之处在于，这并没有说明系统的问题所在，也没有说它应该有什么不同。这只是像在说，我要把手放在天平上，因为我们需要这里发生点什么。所以，人们问为什么这个2024年的研究在26年还有意义。我本想说出来的，结果完全忘了。其中一件事挺有趣的，以后再细说，抱歉，
a big aside at the beginning, but Biden sent when he was elected this packet to clinics with, when you do your, when you have to like do a bunch of paperwork for the center for like mental health, like every year you get these big packs from these different organizations. And he sent a thing that was like, I want there to be a new PTSD treatments. I want there to be new drug treatments that are like cheap and good and healthy.
开头跑题太远了，但拜登当选时，给诊所发了一个包裹，当你必须为心理健康中心做一大堆文书工作时，每年你都会从这些不同的组织收到这些大包裹。他发了一份东西，上面写着，我希望有新的PTSD治疗方法。我希望有新的药物治疗方法，既便宜又好且健康。
And we're going to like award money and you need to submit the this information. And I was like, I'm really sure that this is not going to include the thing that I just patented. That more information on this later, but we have a book and a patent and we kind of found this new brain pathway that does different things. Some people may know more about it than others than listen to the show, but there hadn't been anything on the show about it yet. And he was like, I'll see if this works. And you needed like a million dollars to even begin to proceed with this thing where he was being like, we're willing to look at grassroots. Anyone? No, this is a game that you were not allowed to play. And that's kind of how it works. And so, you know, I don't think that it was really like a good faith move by Trump or Biden.
我们要奖励资金，你需要提交这些信息。当时我就想，我非常确定这不会包括我刚刚申请专利的东西。关于这个以后再说，但我们有一本书和一个专利，我们发现了一条新的大脑通路，它能做不同的事情。有些人可能比听这个节目的其他人更了解它，但节目里还没提过。他当时说，我看看这行不行。你甚至需要一百万美元才能开始进行这个项目，而他却表现得好像，我们愿意看看草根阶层。有人吗？不，这是一个你不被允许玩的游戏。事情就是这样运作的。所以，你知道，我不认为这是特朗普或拜登的善意之举。
I think it was them saying, what is the thing that I can do to make mental health care look like I care about it while pissing off the least people who are wealthy. And if you throw a whole lot of money at a drug company to own a private patent, you don't piss anyone off. When you start saying like, hey, maybe we should regulate insurance or have like Medicaid for all or something, then you tend to start making people scared. So it's not, or when you say, let's change the way we do research or let's look at research that might actually reflect science, those would be political actions. You know, these things, not so much. But anyway, that's why it's back in the news. So going back to this sort of synthesis of oil empire and bureaucracy.
我认为他们是在说，我能做什么来让心理健康护理看起来像是我很关心它，同时又不去激怒那些富有的人。如果你向一家制药公司投入大量资金让他们拥有私人专利，你就不会激怒任何人。当你开始说，嘿，也许我们应该监管保险，或者实行全民医疗补助之类的，那你往往就开始让人感到害怕了。所以不是，或者当你说，让我们改变我们做研究的方式，或者让我们看看可能真正反映科学的研究，那些将是政治行动。你知道，这些事情，没那么政治。但无论如何，这就是它回到新闻中的原因。所以回到石油、帝国和官僚机构的这种综合体。
You know, like, one of the things that is really interesting to me, it sort of changed the way that I read ancient texts, especially the Old Testament, like the Bible, is there was a professor who told me when I was in comparative religion school that basically like when you're in the Bronze Age and you're wandering around in the desert, the most valuable research,
你知道，有一件事让我非常感兴趣，它改变了我阅读古代文本的方式，尤其是旧约，比如圣经，那就是我在比较宗教学学校时，一位教授告诉我，基本上当你处于青铜时代，在沙漠里游荡时，最有价值的资源，
you can have, like one of them that is perishable. It's not like an imperishable resource like gold or like a, you know, a cool like sword or something. So I'm going to metal would be oil or fat, which is the same thing, oil and fat. You've used fat just to render oil, whether you're getting it from an olive or you're getting it from like mutton or something. And you have to choose basically because it does go bad eventually. Do I want the calories from this? Like do I want to eat it to like have my army march across the desert? Or do I want to want to. to turn it into light. If I turn it into light, then I can get work done when it's dark.
你可以拥有的，比如其中一种易腐烂的。它不像黄金或，你知道，一把很酷的剑之类的东西那样是不朽的资源。所以金属会是石油或脂肪，它们是一回事，石油和脂肪。你用脂肪来提炼油，无论你是从橄榄中提取，还是从羊肉之类的东西中提取。你必须做出选择，因为它最终会变质。我想要这些卡路里吗？比如我想吃掉它来让我的军队穿过沙漠吗？还是我想把它变成光？如果我把它变成光，那么当黑暗时我就可以完成工作。
I can have security at night. I can do these different things. And that so much of the Old Testament is like written with that calculus of like, and so like there's a lot of Psalms in the Bible. There's a lot of descriptions of God, especially in the Old Testament, where they're like, heaven or God is like so good that you can have light and you can have food at the same time. You don't have to pick. You get to have light and you get to have food.
我可以在晚上获得安全。我可以做这些不同的事情。旧约中很大一部分就是用这种计算方式写成的，比如，圣经中有很多诗篇。旧约中有很多对上帝的描述，他们说，天堂或上帝是如此美好，以至于你可以同时拥有光和食物。你不需要做出选择。你可以既有光又有食物。
And if you're not from this time, like that's a kind of calculus that you're maybe just not hearing, you know, in the text. But it would be the way that somebody from this age was thinking because it was a calculus that they were running all the time. Do I want calories out of this or do I want extra labor hours, you know, protection? and, you know, a ton of, you know, going back to the Odyssey. Like when you're reading the Odyssey, this isn't necessarily in the Christopher Nolan movie because there's an age gap between Athena and Odysseus. So it'd be kind of weird maybe. But one of the things that is like a big signal of wealth is that somebody is coated in
如果你不是那个时代的人，那是一种你可能根本听不出来的计算方式，你知道，在文本中。但这会是那个时代的人思考的方式，因为它是一种他们一直在进行的计算。我想要从中获得卡路里，还是想要额外的劳动时间，你知道，保护？而且，你知道，大量的，回到《奥德赛》。当你阅读《奥德赛》时，这不一定在克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影里，因为雅典娜和奥德修斯之间有年龄差距。所以可能有点奇怪。但财富的一个重要标志是某人身上涂满了
oil, that their hair is oily and that is specifically in the Odyssey, olive oil, that their skin is like greasy and light reflecting and beautiful. And like every time in the epic point before Odysseus goes somewhere, and Athena's like, wait, wait, wait, I want them to know that you're like a trustworthy, cool guy. I don't want them to think you're a crazy guy that's been homeless on the ocean. Let me rub you down with oil right fast. And then Athena gets all this oil and she rubs Odysseus down right before he meets people
油，他们的头发是油腻的，在《奥德赛》中特别提到是橄榄油，他们的皮肤是油光发亮、美丽动人的。而且史诗中每次在奥德修斯去某个地方之前，雅典娜都会说，等等，等等，我希望他们知道你是一个值得信赖、很酷的人。我不希望他们认为你是一个在海洋上无家可归的疯子。让我快点给你涂上油。然后雅典娜拿了所有的油，在奥德修斯见到那些人之前给他涂上，
who he needs to impress, like right before he goes back home. And so that the last episode, like I ended it with that idea from the Odyssey. that, you know, everyone, Odysseus says, you know, verbatim at the end of the movie, you know, basically everyone who can write is about to die. Like, we're going into a dark age. And I think Christopher Nolan is making that movie because he kind of thinks that we're going into a dark age. Maybe not for the reasons that I do, but, you know, there's enough parody that we both see that happening. And so he says, you know, Odysseus says, this story will only survive if people sing it. It'll be an oral story. It's, you know, him playing with the historicity of the,
他需要给他们留下深刻印象，就像在他回家之前一样。所以上一集，我以《奥德赛》中的那个想法结束了。你知道，每个人，奥德修斯在电影结尾逐字逐句地说，你知道，基本上所有会写字的人都要死了。我们要进入黑暗时代了。我认为克里斯托弗·诺兰拍那部电影是因为他觉得我们正在进入一个黑暗时代。也许原因和我不同，但，你知道，有足够的相似之处让我们都看到了这一点。所以他说，你知道，奥德修斯说，这个故事只有在人们传唱时才会流传下去。它将是一个口头故事。这是，你知道，他在玩弄他所改编的文本的历史性。
the text that he's adapting. And, you know, that that is true. Like in if you look at like, I don't know, 1,300, 300 BC, there's this, you know, Eastern Mediterranean, like, world. And it just completely goes down. You have all of these droughts and weather patterns and empire's collapsing and refugees coming. You know, Egypt gets invaded by all these people just showing up to the point where they can't continue their empire because it just becomes too porous. You had a whole other empire move on top of the land that your empire was on. And it breaks things. You have like the Mycenaeans, the Greeks, and you have the Hittite kingdom. I know collapse is about the same time. But all that's like part of the Bronze Age collapse. One of the things that
而且，你知道，那是真的。如果你看看，我不知道，公元前1300年、300年，有这个，你知道，东地中海，那个世界。它完全崩溃了。你有所有的干旱和天气模式，帝国崩溃，难民涌入。你知道，埃及被所有这些出现的人入侵，以至于他们无法维持他们的帝国，因为它变得太脆弱了。你有另一个帝国移动到你帝国所在的土地上。它破坏了事物。你有迈锡尼人、希腊人，还有赫梯王国。我知道崩溃大约在同一时间。但所有这些都是青铜时代崩溃的一部分。其中一件事
you see like an Egyptian text at this time is like pictures of people with like weird stuff on boats that you normally wouldn't have on boats. You could identify like is that a worship or is that like, you know, a grain barge or is just like a trader who's going somewhere. And you see people that have like buildings and furniture and all this stuff on boats because an entire empire is like invading Egypt, you know, by by sea and by water. And it destabilizes everything. So, uh, when you know, a lot of a lot of that they talk about the sea peoples in the Christopher Nolan movie. The sea peoples are coming. And there's these raiders, you know, that the Egyptians carve a bunch of this stuff. And they show that all these people were coming by sea. Now, the Hittites, the people were
你在那个时代的埃及文本中看到的是，人们在船上带着奇怪的东西，你通常不会在船上看到这些。你可以识别出，那是战舰，还是，你知道，运粮船，还是只是一个去某地的商人。你看到人们在船上带着建筑物、家具和所有这些东西，因为整个帝国正在通过海路入侵埃及。它破坏了一切。所以，当你知道，他们中的很多人在克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影里谈论海上民族。海上民族来了。有这些掠夺者，你知道，埃及人雕刻了很多这些东西。他们展示了所有这些人都是通过海路来的。现在，赫梯人，人们是
coming by land into their kingdom. But, you know, the best guess is that there was not really this huge outside enemy, that it was like the system just being put to the test where it couldn't absorb the amount of migration that was going to happen. And a lot of these, people were moving from, you know, what essentially is like Europe into this other area because there's this drought and this famine. But in the Odyssey movie that Christopher Nolan does, he basically says, you know, Odysseus wandering at sea and creating all of this chaos and creating all of this, you know, violence while he's trying to get back home is the sea peoples that the people in Greece are afraid of. So he's kind of playing with this idea that like maybe the empire ends when the
通过陆路进入他们的王国。但是，你知道，最好的猜测是，并没有真正存在这个巨大的外部敌人，而是系统受到了考验，无法吸收将要发生的移民数量。很多这些人，是从，你知道，本质上是欧洲的地方移动到这个其他区域，因为有干旱和饥荒。但在克里斯托弗·诺兰拍摄的《奥德赛》电影中，他基本上说，你知道，奥德修斯在海上游荡，制造了所有这些混乱，并在他试图回家时制造了所有这些，你知道，暴力，就是希腊人害怕的海上民族。所以他是在玩弄这个想法，即帝国可能在帝国的前线回家时结束。
front of the empire comes home. When you start treating the people at home the same way that the empire used to always treat the people out there. And this sort of, you know, Greek empire or the imperial coalition that's just conquered Troy in the Iliad is not going to survive those veterans coming home in the Odyssey, even if it takes them 10 years to get back. You know, the violence that an empire sends out to the periphery comes back and then lands on its core that's not really a theme in the original odyssey it can be read out of it it is the way that christopher nolan is reading it because of the point that he's trying to make um because no one even though it's not really set up that well in that movie um because there's only like one scene of odysseus burning down a village it's implied that odysseus has been sort of killing a whole lot of people
当你开始以帝国过去对待外面的人的方式对待家里的人时。这种，你知道，希腊帝国或在《伊利亚特》中刚刚征服特洛伊的帝国联盟，在《奥德赛》中是无法在那些老兵回家后幸存下来的，即使他们花了10年才回来。你知道，帝国向边缘地带输出的暴力回流并降临到其核心，这在原始《奥德赛》中并不是一个主题，它可以被解读出来，这是克里斯托弗·诺兰解读它的方式，因为他试图表达的观点。因为没有人，尽管在电影中并没有很好地表现出来，因为只有一场奥德修斯烧毁村庄的戏，暗示奥德修斯一直在杀很多人
to stay alive and get back home. And then he's been seen as this Viking raider that even though it's one guy, his homeland is becoming unstable based on the fear that he's causing in the periphery by the time he gets back home. And I kind of have issues with Nolan as a director because he's amazing.
为了活下去并回家。然后他被视为维京掠夺者，即使只有一个人，他的家乡也因为他在边缘地带造成的恐惧而变得不稳定。我对诺兰作为导演有一些看法，因为他很棒。
Like there's a shot in the Elliott, I mean, there's a shot in the Odyssey where it's the shot of Penelope looking through the loom that she's weaving on. And there's this large format, you know, IMAX lens, that just turns that fabric in front of her into this,
比如《伊利亚特》中有一个镜头，我是说，《奥德赛》中有一个镜头，是佩内洛普透过她正在编织的织布机看过去的镜头。有一个大画幅，你知道，IMAX镜头，把她面前的织物变成了这个，
this cream that colors her face and the color's perfect. And it's probably my favorite shot in any movie ever. So it's like no one will do things like that. But then also like when it comes to action, he can't really direct action. The Batman movies, everyone will get mad at me because they'll be like, those are action movies. No, they're not.
这种奶油色，给她的脸着色，颜色非常完美。这可能是我在任何电影中最喜欢的镜头。所以诺兰会做这样的事情。但当涉及到动作时，他真的不会执导动作戏。《蝙蝠侠》电影，每个人都会对我生气，因为他们会说，那是动作电影。不，它们不是。
There's very little action in that. You know, it's like the language of heists. It's the language of film noir. It's a language of detective movies. there's only like three or four action scenes in those movies and they're not very good. You know, like a giant airplane being grabbed by another airplane out of the sky and Batman. That's not really action. Like, you know, like that's a different genre that he's using to do this.
里面几乎没有动作。你知道，这是抢劫片的语言。这是黑色电影的语言。这是侦探电影的语言。那些电影里只有三四场动作戏，而且拍得不是很好。你知道，比如一架巨大的飞机在天空中被另一架飞机抓住，在《蝙蝠侠》里。那不是真正的动作。就像，你知道，那是他用来做这件事的另一种类型。
And then he also, he writes theme and tone beautifully. Like he writes things in movies that you can't really normally say because people would be like, you're just saying like the theme out loud. But for some reason when he writes that, it works. you know like an interstellar when they're like maybe quantum physics is like a force that ripples throughout the universe but also like love could be a force like that too you're like man this dialogue shouldn't work and it kind of does what he can't write is dialogue when he's not writing theme and tone so i i i anyway i i see those as problems but one of the reasons why the movie is so
而且他还非常漂亮地写出了主题和基调。他写电影里的东西，你通常不能说出来，因为人们会说，你只是把主题大声说出来了。但出于某种原因，当他写那个时，它奏效了。你知道，就像在《星际穿越》里，当他们说也许量子物理学是一种在宇宙中涟漪的力量，但也像爱可能是一种那样的力量，你会觉得，伙计，这段对话不应该奏效，但它确实奏效了。他写不了的是当他不写主题和基调时的对话。所以我，我，无论如何，我把这些看作问题，但电影之所以如此
beautiful it really works is that he does theme and tone in a complex and nuanced way that works really, really well. So that theme of the Bronze Age collapse being something that everyone could see coming and no one could prevent. And also it was kind of the fault of the people doing it. I think is something that Nolan is trying to, you know, indict us right now so that we see what, what is happening to our culture. And, you know, a lot of this stuff is self-evident. We can see these bureaucracies. We know how they work. We know how dumb they are. And we're still really not able to push back against them or change. So the last episode I said when several episodes I've said that I think that we're kind of moving into this like epic of just dissociation as a nation. And the poem,
美丽，它确实奏效了，是因为他以一种复杂且微妙的方式处理主题和基调，效果非常好。所以青铜时代崩溃是每个人都能预见且无人能阻止的事情，而且在某种程度上是那些制造它的人的错，这个主题，我认为是诺兰试图，你知道，现在起诉我们，以便我们看到我们的文化正在发生什么。而且，你知道，很多这些东西是不言自明的。我们可以看到这些官僚机构。我们知道它们是如何运作的。我们知道它们有多愚蠢。但我们仍然无法反击或改变。所以上一集我说，当几集我都说过，我认为我们作为一个国家正在进入这种解离的史诗。而那首诗，
the Odyssey, that's what Nolan is taking out of it accurately. The ending of the Odyssey is this giant national dissociation by a god, the epic, not the movie, where, Athena comes down and says the civil war that's happening in Ithaca where all of the nobles are killing each other the only way this is ever going to work is if I basically erase all of their minds and you have this like little
《奥德赛》，这就是诺兰从中准确提取的东西。《奥德赛》的结尾是神进行的一场巨大的国家解离，史诗，不是电影，雅典娜下来并说，伊萨卡正在发生的内战，所有的贵族都在互相残杀，唯一能让这一切奏效的方法就是我基本上抹去他们所有的记忆，然后你有了这个，你知道，梦幻般的结局，它回到了以前的样子，即使奥德修斯已经离开了10年，现在他回到了佩内洛普身边，你知道，王位继承人的正确轨迹已经随着特勒马科斯恢复了，
dreamlike ending where it goes back to the way it was before and even though Odysseus has been gone for 10 years now he's back with Penelope and you know the right trajectory of the heir to the throne has been with Telemachus has been restored
但这是通过抹去所有这些人的记忆，基本上让他们忘记了权力真空导致他们发生的暴力。然后我们在《奥德赛》之后有了所有这些史诗，奥德修斯不是一个好人，工作的暴力并没有消失，它不断回到家里。而诺兰实际上引用了一些那些东西，比我想象的要多。我没有，我以为他只是会拿那首诗，然后用它做他想做的事。但他确实写了一些东西，这些东西与青铜时代衰落的历史，也就是制造它的人的真实历史，在进行对话。同时，还有《奥德赛》之前，你知道，或在《奥德赛》和《伊利亚特》中间的所有那些小史诗的扩展虚构历史。
but that is by wiping the minds of all these people, basically having them forget the violence that the power vacuum made them happen. And then we have all of these epic poems after the Odyssey where Odysseus is like not a nice guy, where the violence of the work doesn't go away, where it keeps coming back home. And Nolan actually references some of that stuff a little bit, more so than I thought. I didn't, I thought he was just going to kind of take the poem and then do something that he wanted to do with it. But he does write things where this thing is in conversation with like the history of the fall of the Bronze Age, like the real history of the people that made it. And at the same time, the extended sort of fictional history of all of the little epic poems that were before the Odyssey, you know, or in the middle of the Odyssey and the L.A.N.
或者在它们之后，你知道，比如奥德修斯和瑟西还有另一个儿子。我们没有那首诗，但特勒戈诺斯（Telegonus），我的希腊语不太好。但他基本上回家了，他和瑟西有一个儿子，那个儿子最终回到了伊萨卡，有一场血腥的清算，你知道，它是更大故事的一部分，即使并非所有这些都幸存下来，我们通过其他人谈论它而知道它。诺兰把那首诗的整个道德世界压缩成宙斯法则这个概念，这是一种过度简化，但这是一部电影，我会允许它。他说，你知道，在真正的希腊传统中，那会被称为“Xenia”，你知道，这种宾主友谊，
Or after them, you know, like Odysseus has another son with Cersi. We don't have that poem, but Talogynus or telegamous, my Greek is not great. but he basically he comes home he has a son with sercy and that son eventually comes back to itica and there is a bloody reckoning and you know there are it's part of a bigger story even though not all of that survives we know it by other people talking about it and no one like compresses that whole moral world of the poem into this idea of the law of zeus which is an oversimplification but it's a movie like i'll allow it and he says you know the the in the the real Greek tradition, that would be what you call zinia, you know, this guest friendship,
宾主关系，你知道，在问名字之前喂养陌生人的义务。你不知道他是贵族还是贫穷的乞丐，因为他可能是伪装的神。你可能会因为没有，你知道，喂养他而受到惩罚。你知道，在青铜时代，那不是礼貌。那是国际秩序。那是做这些事的人是希腊人，他们的秩序，他们是秩序，而那些不这样做的人，那些可能因为你信仰不同的神而杀了你的人，那是混乱。那是帝国的边缘。那是黑暗。而我们是光明。所以当你开始
the guest host relationship, you know, the duty to feed the stranger before you ask his name. You don't know if he's a noble or if he's a impoverished beggar because he may be a god in disguise. And you may be punished for not, you know, feeding him. You know, in the Bronze Age, that wasn't manners. It was international order. It was the people who do this are Greek, their order, they are chaos, and the people who don't do that, who might just kill you because you believe in a different God, that's chaos. That is the edges of the empire. That is the darkness. And we are the light. So when you start to
让那种道德秩序崩溃，当你开始让那些规则和规范以及事物瓦解时，你正在把黑暗带入光明。你正在把混乱带入帝国的中心。这些戏剧中有很多是为了提醒人们他们必须这样做。你知道，文化是在挑选反映它认为最必要的规则的艺术作品。而《奥德赛》就是它挑选的那一个。它幸存了下来。你知道，那些不遵守宙斯法则，不遵守宾主关系的人，他们是地图的边缘。他们是怪物。你知道，独眼巨人吃他的客人。你知道，亚马逊人在神话中偶尔有用，但实际上他们是那种可怕的
have that moral order crumble, when you start to have those rules and norms and things break down, you're bringing the darkness into the light. You're bringing the chaos into the center of the empire. And so much of these plays were written to remind people that they had to do this. You know, culture is picking the works of art that reflect the rules that it knows are the most necessary. And the Odyssey is kind of the one that it picked. It survived. You know, the other people who don't do the law of Zeus, who don't do the guest host relationship, they're the edge of the map. They're they're monsters. You know, the Cyclops eats his guests. You know, the Amazon's are sometimes useful in mythology, but really they're kind of the scary
群体，当他们出现时可能不会和我们配合，或者埃塞俄比亚人，你知道。瑟西把人变成动物。她比人类更好。她被神赋予了这些天赋，但怪物只是怪物。他有一句台词我很喜欢。当奥德修斯试图走另一条路，他试图走得比他应该走的更远。
group that may not play ball with us when they show up or the Ethiopians, you know. The Searcy turns people into animals. She is better than human. She's given these gifts by the gods, but the monsters are just monsters. He does a line that I like a lot. When Odysseus is trying to go a different way, and he's trying to go further west than he's supposed to go.
人们说，如果你去那里，你不会喜欢你所看到的。他们让他知道他正在离开世界，世界的中心。而且，你知道，观点引导你经历所有这些事情。而且你确实感觉到，你知道，电影之所以奏效是因为你觉得你离开了地图。你离开了真实世界。你处于这种怪物的地方，而奥德修斯正试图回家。如果他能回家，那么他就能回到帝国的中心。
The people say, if you go there, you will not like what you see. And they're letting him know he's kind of leaving the world, the center of the world. And, you know, the point walks you through all of those things. And you do feel, you know, the movie works because you feel like you left the map. You left the real world. And you're in this place of kind of monsters and Odysseus is trying to get home. If you can just get home, then he'll be able to back in the center of the empire.
电影结尾的高潮是意识到我把混乱带回家了。我创造了它。我把它带到了这里。而且因为我们与宙斯法则妥协了，我们实际上摧毁了家是什么，再也没有家可以回了。但这些东西的这种崩溃有多少听起来很熟悉？就像，只是时事，伙计，就像我们过去常打仗，即使他们是邪恶的，即使他们是坏的，你知道？
And the realization and the climax of the end of the movie is that I brought the chaos home. I created it. I brought it here. And because we made compromises with the law of Zeus, we've actually. destroyed what home was and there's no home to go back to anymore. But how much of this kind of breakdown of these things sounds familiar? Like, just current events, man, like we used to fight, even if they were evil, even if they were bad, you know?
战争过去是为了土地、港口、金钱或自身利益之类的东西而战。而且，你知道，它们是贪婪的、可怕的事情，你知道，美国历史已经做过了。你知道每个国家可能都做过，但你可以阅读账本，你可以看出鲜血是为了什么，帝国在那里买了什么。它有一种逻辑，即使它是不道德的或违背你的道德。你看看像霍尔木兹海峡发生的事情，它让帝国付出代价，却没有任何回报，因为我们不是为了物质奖励而做那件事，这是一种奇怪的感觉，因为即使我不同意过去发生的战争。它们仍然是因为一个我能理解的原因而发生的，
Wars used to be fought for things like land or like ports or money or like self-interest. And, you know, they were greedy, monstrous things that, you know, American history has done. that you know the history of every country you know probably has done but you could read the ledger and you could kind of see what the blood was for like what the empire was buying there was a logic to it even if it was immoral or it was against your morality you look at something like what's going on in the strait of Hormuz it costs an empire and there's nothing in return like we're not doing that for a material reward which is a weird feeling because even if I disagreed with wars that were happening in the past. Like, they were still happening because of a reason that I understood
或者人们可以推断出的原因，即使他们不同意。你看看这个，这几乎就像否认，否认一个古老的帝国自我结构正在崩溃。这甚至不是一场为了资源的战争。它感觉更像是戏剧，表演出来是为了让帝国可以继续试图相信某些东西或断言某些东西，如果它需要断言它，那它一定觉得它不是真的，因为不安全感就是这样运作的。而且，你知道，我们谈论过，你知道，像上一集里的降落伞问题，像那些无法承认皇帝没穿衣服的组织的不安全感。我试图把这些东西放在一起。我试图写这篇关于《奥德赛》的文章。我试图写这篇关于最近的，
or a reason that people could, could infer, even if they disagreed with it. You look at this, and it's almost like denial, denial that an old imperial egoic structure is breaking down. It's not even a war for resources. It feels more like theater, performed so that the empire can keep trying to believe something or assert something that it must not feel as true if it needs to assert it because that's how insecurity works. And, you know, we've talked about, you know, like the parachute problem in the last episode, like the idea of the insecurity of these organizations that can't admit that the emperor has no clothes. I'm trying to bring these things together. I tried to write this essay on the Odyssey. I tried to write this essay on like the post
你知道，官僚机构以及美国神话的心理历史学现在正在对心理学做什么的文章，因为当你接近这样一个系列的未来时，要务实和政治化就更难了。你知道，不是每个人，外面没有很多亨利·福特的粉丝。你越接近80年代和90年代，人们就开始生气。然后还有关于帝国和石油本身的本质。就像作为一个实际的事情。它们变成了一堆笔记，希望我能在这次谈话中把飞机降落，你知道，经历它，因为它们似乎都在对我表达同样的事情。你知道，简·布洛克斯是我告诉你关于那个教授的事情的人。它来自，你知道，很久以前，她是写那本书的人。我想它叫《启蒙》。我不记得了。封面上有一个灯泡。我在2004年左右读过它。但她的书里有这样一个地方，你知道，她在谈论人们对光、对石油有一种深层的、饥渴，呃，她是那个谈论青铜时代事物的人，就像，你必须把石油作为食物，或者，卡路里，或者卡路里，或者卡路里是光，基本上。嗯，她，但她谈论，你知道，像整个舰队为了鲸鱼搜寻地球，你知道，在大英帝国。
recent, you know, bureaucracy in what the psycho history of American mythology is doing the psychology right now because it's harder to be pragmatic and political as you creep up on the future of a series like that. You know, not everyone, there's not a lot of Henry Ford fans out there. You get closer to the 80s and 90s, people start to get mad. And then also just about the nature of of like empire and oil itself. Like just as a practical thing. And they kind of became this collection of notes that hopefully I can land the plane on this talk, you know, going through it because they all sort of seemed like they were
他们获取石油，就像这是一个巨大的国家项目，一个经济项目，你必须找到，你知道，这个巨大的时期，直到有替代品。而且就像旧约中有很多上帝的善良是石油，一遍又一遍，石油让脸发亮，那对一个人的头涂抹一杯油的膏油，上帝是这种石油的物质过剩，基本上，只是这些家伙一遍又一遍地建立的联系。你知道，出埃及记，圣殿，他们告诉灯要持续燃烧压榨的橄榄油。就像，有所有这些过剩的迹象。我会继续谈论石油在青铜时代有多重要。但是，你知道，这种物质的想法，它有点像
saying the same thing to me. You know, Jane Brock's is the person who I told you that thing about the professor. It came from, you know, a really long time ago that she was the one who wrote the book. I think it's called Illumination. I don't remember. It has a light bulb on the cover. I read it in like 2004. But her book has this place where, you know, she's talking about how there's this deep, like, hunger for light for oil, uh, that, uh, she's the one that was talking about the Bronze Age things are being like, you have to either do oil as food or, uh, calories or calories or calories are light, basically. Um, and she, but she talks about, you know, like the, the whole like fleets scouring the planet for whales, you know, in the British Empire.
帝国的重点和燃料，但也正是这种，我们知道我们永远无法拥有足够的东西，因为它是我们所有野心的燃料，以及这是一种多么有趣的想法。我在想乔治·巴塔耶。他在30年代写作，我想40年代也写，他说文明的定义问题不是稀缺。定义问题是剩余。你知道，每个社会生产的都比它需要的多。而过剩必须去某个地方。
they were they were getting oil like it was this it was the source of oil that became this enormous national project an economic project that you to find you know this enormous period until there was a replacement and like so much of like the old testament there's this goodness of god is oil over and over that oil makes faces bright that the anointing um of a you know the head with a cup of oil, God is this material excess of oil, basically, is just a connection that these guys make over and over again. You know, Exodus, the temple, they tell the lamp to burn the beaten olive oil continuously. Like, there's all these signs of excess. I'm going to keep talking about how important oil was in the Bronze Age. But, you know, this idea of this substance that is sort of like
而且，你知道，人们如何消耗过剩实际上才是真正的事情。那是你可以了解他们是谁的事情，不是什么稀缺，而是他们如何处理剩余。所以，你知道，他相当深奥。但他所说的一件事是，有一种牺牲，节日、大教堂、锤在天花板上的黄金，你知道，没有人从中获利。所以无用的支出是文化如何真正触及神圣，因为它是那个行为，而神圣是它最高的理想，不是实际上，你知道，不是字面上的神圣的东西，但你知道，它可能是试图那样做。但它是唯一站在账本之外的行为。如果你看看我们正在做的事情
the point and the fuel of empire, but also this, this thing that we know we can never have enough of, because it is the fuel for all of our ambitions and how that is kind of an interesting idea. I was thinking about George Batai. He's writing in the 30s and in the, I think the 40s too, and he says that the defining problem of civilization is not scarcity. The defining problem is surplus. You know, every society produces more than it needs. And the excess has to go somewhere.
用我们现在拥有的剩余，随着人工智能，随着我们以牺牲其他投资为代价所做的投资而耗尽的剩余。那是我们正在伸手去够的一个非常可怕的上帝，你知道，以一种世俗的方式。这是一个隐喻。但美国如何使用它的过剩。这说明了我们是谁？你知道，艾伦·斯托克尔，他带着巴塔耶某种程度上在玩弄的想法。当他说我们从未真正停止制造伟大的无用支出。
And, you know, how people burn off excess is actually the real thing. That's the thing that you can know about who they are, not what's scarce, what they do with surplus. And so, you know, he's pretty dense. But one of the things he's saying is that there's this sacrifice where the festival, the cathedral, the gold hammered into the ceiling, you know, nobody profits from that. So useless spending is how a culture actually touches the sacred because it's the one that the act and the sacred being like its highest ideal there, not actually, you know, not literally something holy, but you know, it could be trying to do that. But it's the one act that stands outside of the ledger. And if you look at what we're doing
我们只是改变了祭坛，因为巴塔耶正在写关于分析过去的文章。他说，你知道，通勤现在是牺牲。它是高速公路上八车道的互换车道。所有这些都是你基本上在使用古代阳光，你知道，困在石油里，你从地下提取的化石燃料。这就是你如何解锁那种能量。这就是你用它做的事情。石油是这种宗教，石油，
with the surplus that we have right now, the surplus that is running out with things like AI, with things like the investments that we're making at the expense of other investments. That is a very scary God that we are reaching for, you know, in a secular way. This is a metaphor. But what is how America uses its excess. What does that say about who we are? You know, Alan Stokel, he carried this idea that Batai sort of plays with. when he says that we never really stopped making the great useless expenditure.
是现代的这种宗教，在我们实际实践的东西中，尽管我们说了什么。而光荣消费的冲动并没有消失。它只是通过汽车的燃料箱被重新路由了，我们忘记了那是崇拜。但我们看待汽车和交通
We just sort of changed the altar because Batai is writing about analyzing the past. And he says, you know, the commute is the sacrifice now. It's the eight lane interchangeable, you know, lanes on the highway. That all is what you're using basically ancient sunlight, you know, stuck in the oil, fossil fuels that you're pulling out of the ground. that's how you're unlocking that energy. That's what you're doing with that. Oil is this religion, petroleum,
作为我们独立身份不可或缺的一部分。而且，你知道，回到《奥德赛》，那在《奥德赛》中也显得格格不入。在第19卷中，奥德修斯夺回大厅的前一天晚上，他和他的儿子把所有的武器从大厅搬走以伏击追求者，雅典娜走在他前面，拿着这盏金灯，它用如此奇怪的光填满了大厅，以至于特勒马科斯说家里一定有神。那是荷马中唯一一次提到灯。并没有真正的灯。
is this religion of the modern age in what we actually practice, despite what we say. And the urge to spend gloriously didn't disappear. It just got rerouted through the tank of the fuel tank of the car, and we forgot that it was worship. But we view cars and transportation
到处都是火把。到处都是壁炉。但油灯在书中24卷里只出现了一次。当那光是神圣的并且由神拿着时，她就像是在给他们许可去做这种对追求者耍花招的事情。但她允许他们稍微打破神的法则，并用这种奇怪的光照亮他们的道路。而且，你知道，美国与石油的关系是如此奇怪，因为，就像，这就像一个简单的笑话。
as such an indispensable part of our independent identity. And, you know, that going back to the Odyssey, that jars in the Odyssey too. In book 19, the night before Odysseus takes back the hall, he and his son move all the weapons out of the great room to ambush the suitors, and Athena walks ahead of him, holding this golden lamp, and it fills the hall with light so strange that Talamicus says that a god must be in the house. And that's the only mention of a lamp in Homer. There's not really lamps.
作为我们独立身份不可或缺的一部分。你知道，回到《奥德赛》，《奥德赛》里也有这种不协调感。在第19卷中，就在奥德修斯夺回大厅的前一天晚上，他和儿子把所有武器从大厅搬走，准备伏击求婚者。雅典娜走在他前面，手里拿着一盏金灯，大厅里充满了奇异的光芒，以至于特勒马科斯说家里一定有神灵。那是荷马史诗中唯一一次提到灯。其实并没有灯。
There's torches everywhere. There's hearths everywhere. but the oil lamp appears once, you know, in 24 books of that book. And when that light is sacred and it's held by a god, she's like sort of giving them permission to do this tricksy thing with the suitors. But she's allowing them to break the law of the gods a little bit and sort of lighting their path with this like weird light. And like America's relationship to oil is so weird because like it's like an easy joke
到处都是火把，到处都是壁炉。但油灯在全书24卷中只出现过一次。当那道光是神圣的，并且由一位女神拿着时，她就像是在某种程度上允许他们对求婚者做这种狡猾的事情。但她允许他们稍微打破神的法则，用这种奇怪的光照亮他们的道路。而且美国与石油的关系非常奇怪，就像一个容易被拿来开玩笑的梗。
that people will be like, oh, that's just capitalism or like it's a war for oil. oil people have said not just about this word. I mean, I've been hearing that since I was in middle school about anything that we did. But then nobody really feels like there's, it just, it feels like something you say, not really a reality that you're interacting with. I mean, I remember like in 2012, I was watching the Mitt Romney and Barack Obama debate. And, you know, they always like the Republicans have to be like, I like oil. We could get all this free oil if we just did these things. And then the Democrats have to be like, we have to balance. you know, the economy, but also the environment and also the poor, whatever they're pretending to be moderate about in that cycle. And like Romney said that if he was president, he would, we would be oil independent in like two years or something. Then America would basically just make all of its own oil and it wouldn't need to import all this oil anymore. And I was like watching that. I was like, that's crazy. Like, people don't understand how these things work. Like,
人们会说，哦，那只是资本主义，或者那是一场石油战争。石油相关人士不仅针对这个词这么说。我的意思是，从我上中学起，无论我们做什么，我一直都在听到这种说法。但后来没人真的觉得有什么，这感觉就像是你随口说说而已，而不是你真正参与其中的现实。我的意思是，我记得2012年的时候，我在看米特·罗姆尼和巴拉克·奥巴马的辩论。你知道，共和党人总是不得不说，我喜欢石油。如果我们做了这些事，我们就能得到所有这些免费的石油。然后民主党人就得说，我们必须平衡，你知道，经济，还有环境，还有穷人，无论他们在那个周期里假装对什么持温和态度。罗姆尼说，如果他当选总统，我们大约两年内就能实现石油独立之类的。然后美国基本上就能自己生产所有的石油，不再需要进口这么多石油了。我当时看着那个，心想，这太疯狂了。人们根本不了解这些东西是怎么运作的，比如，
crude oil is not just like this thing where you're like, okay, I found it. It's black goop. Let me throw it in the still. Like it's, I'm going to make whiskey and then the still bubbles and then gasoline drips out. Now I have petroleum gas. Like crude oil is not just one substance. Like a barrel of crude oil is this tangle of carbon chains of different lengths that thousands of kinds of molecules all mixed together. And the length of the chain decides what molecule it actually is. So the short chains are gases. And then the middle length chains are like good stuff that you actually want, which is kerosene and diesel. And then the really long chains, the energy is like stored.
原油并不是那种你发现它，然后说，好吧，这是黑色粘稠物，让我把它扔进蒸馏器里，就像我要酿威士忌，然后蒸馏器冒泡，汽油就滴出来了，现在我有石油气了。原油不仅仅是一种物质。一桶原油是一团不同长度的碳链，成千上万种分子混合在一起。链的长度决定了它到底是什么分子。所以短链是气体。中间长度的链是像煤油和柴油这样你真正想要的优质产品。然后是非常长的链，能量就像被储存起来了一样。
Well, in the gases, it's stored too excessively. The medium chains is the good stuff where you can actually kind of transport it and have this moderation. And then the really long chains are like complicated waxes and oils that are like too hard. to get the energy out of because you'd have to invest too much energy in it to release the energy that's there like petroleum jelly or something or a lot of the things that cheap candles are made of that you're not really supposed to breathe in by bees well x candles guys um but all of that is in this one barrel another thing a lot of people don't know this but oil is not dinosaur bones oil is algae like 99% of the oil that you burn when you drive your car that was actually algae because
嗯，在气体中，它也储存得过多。中等长度的链是好东西，你可以真正地运输它并进行调节。然后非常长的链就像复杂的蜡和油，太难提取能量了，因为你必须投入太多的能量才能释放出其中的能量，比如凡士林之类的，或者很多廉价蜡烛的成分，你其实不应该吸入这些东西，好吧，蜂蜡蜡烛除外，伙计们。但所有这些都在这一桶油里。还有一件事，很多人不知道，石油不是恐龙骨头，石油是藻类。你开车时燃烧的石油中99%实际上是藻类，因为
all the stuff that's been alive in the planet like we see the little picture of the bronzed or not bronzes we see the little picture of the um paleozoic you know burns and the swamp and you think all that stuff died and it got squished down but like all of that stuff is actually a teeny tiny fraction of the majority of life that's been on this planet the majority of the life that's been on this planet that's been cooked down into oil is from algae and the The energy that's storing is sunlight. When you get in your car and you drive, you were getting the sunlight from four million years ago,
地球上所有曾经活过的东西，就像我们看到的古生代沼泽的小图片，你以为所有那些东西都死了，被压扁了，但所有这些东西实际上只是地球上曾经存在过的绝大多数生命中极小的一部分。地球上曾经存在过的、被烹煮成石油的绝大多数生命都来自藻类，而它储存的能量是阳光。当你上车开车时，你得到的是四百万年前的阳光，
and you were getting the energy that something stored that got through this weird trick about how chemicals work, smushed into these long chains, only the middle of which is useful for you as a car driver, and then hidden under the ground and then pushed up by a salt dome, and then unlocked by a certain kind of refinery. I'm getting back to Romney and Obama, I promise. I'm going to land the plane.
你得到的是某种东西通过化学运作的这种奇怪技巧储存的能量，被挤压成这些长链，其中只有中间部分对你这个司机有用，然后被藏在地下，被盐丘推上来，然后被某种炼油厂解锁。我保证，我会回到罗姆尼和奥巴马的话题上。我会把这个话题讲完的。
But that's what you're doing is you're taking the energy that that plant stored from sunlight. Like in the 80s or the 70s, there was actually like this project where just try and get oil, corn oil, like out of corn and then take the majority of the energy that distilling it is ethanol and then mixing those together and then mixing it with petroleum, which is what we do now to try and make like fake oil as we use corn. It's like really not efficient. And so the biologists basically in the 70s were like, well, if this stuff's algae anyway, and it just takes a really long time, there's this kind of algae that has basically like an oil bloom
但你所做的就是利用植物从阳光中储存的能量。比如在80年代或70年代，实际上有这样一个项目，试图从玉米中提取石油，玉米油，然后把蒸馏它的大部分能量作为乙醇，然后把它们混合在一起，再与石油混合，这就是我们现在所做的，试图制造像假石油一样的东西，我们用玉米。这真的效率不高。所以生物学家在70年代基本上认为，既然这东西反正就是藻类，而且需要很长时间，有一种藻类基本上就像石油爆发一样，
where it like it makes a whole bunch of oil. And so instead of getting like a million years of it, what if we just got it like selectively bred, you know, if we just like, you know, did, you know, plant husbandry and got our Mendel, you know, punant squares and we kept the kind of algae that like produces a lot of oil and then we just grew it in giant swimming pools and then harvested in it and then we could just make synthetic oil which there was a pretty good you know they selectively bred it which takes a long time and then when Reagan came in that seemed like it was too green for him it seemed like it was basically sustainable energy even though the result is still gasoline so he cut all the research and they threw out all of the they threw out all of
它会产生大量的油。所以与其等上一百万年，如果我们只是选择性地培育它，你知道，如果我们只是进行植物培育，拿出我们的孟德尔遗传方格，保留那种产生大量油的藻类，然后我们在巨大的游泳池里种植它，然后收获它，我们就能制造合成油。他们进行了相当不错的选择性培育，这需要很长时间，然后当里根上台时，这对他来说似乎太“绿色”了，这看起来基本上是可持续能源，尽管结果仍然是汽油，所以他削减了所有研究，他们扔掉了所有
the like different algae that they'd been breeding for 10 years and then froze some of it until like the 90s and then through the rest away. And we lost that whole chain of thing. Point being, there are different grades of oil. Okay. And you need different refineries to unlock the complexity of each one of those grades. This is getting back to the Mitt Romney stuff. Oil refineries are not interchangeable at all.
他们培育了10年的不同藻类，然后冷冻了一些直到90年代，然后把剩下的扔掉了。我们失去了整个链条。重点是，石油有不同的等级。好吧。你需要不同的炼油厂来解锁每一个等级的复杂性。这又回到了米特·罗姆尼的话题。炼油厂根本不是可以互换的。
They're actually about a billion dollars different most of the time. One of the reason why we don't build. complex refineries in America is because we will probably be out of oil as a planet by the time anyone who wants to spend that money could recoup any of that investment. You know, each refinery is built for one particular type of crude oil. So light or heavy is the mix of chain lengths and sweet and sour is the amount of sulfur in the oil. Sour crude poisons the wrong kind of equipment, breaks the refinery and then costs you
它们大多数时候的造价相差十亿美元。我们不在美国建造复杂炼油厂的原因之一是，等到任何想花这笔钱的人收回投资时，地球上的石油可能已经用完了。你知道，每个炼油厂都是为一种特定类型的原油建造的。所以轻质或重质是链长的混合，甜味和酸味是石油中硫的含量。酸性原油会毒害错误的设备，损坏炼油厂，然后让你损失
$3 billion and you have to rebuild your whole refinery because you didn't have your engineer do the right thing. So the Gulf Coast refineries, which are the most sophisticated refineries on earth, or the complex refineries on earth, they were tooled up in the 70s and the 80s to eat heavy sour crude from Mexico, Venezuela, and the Gulf states. Because that was what was for sale. So that's why we built them. And then fracking happened. And so it's lightning outside. I don't know if y'all can hear that, but it may be a little loud.
30亿美元，你必须重建整个炼油厂，因为你没有让你的工程师做正确的事。所以墨西哥湾沿岸的炼油厂，也就是地球上最复杂的炼油厂，它们在70年代和80年代被改造，用来处理来自墨西哥、委内瑞拉和海湾国家的重质酸性原油。因为那是当时市场上有的东西。所以这就是我们建造它们的原因。然后水力压裂法出现了。外面在打雷。我不知道你们能不能听到，但声音可能有点大。
So when fracking happened, the shale fields turned out to produce the opposite thing. We never thought we could get light sweet crude here. And then it turned out we had all this light sweet crude. So that's the great kind of oil that we actually want because sour crude has so much sulfur that it builds like really good diesel fuel and really good asphalt. But it doesn't, it's very hard to turn it into petroleum that you would put in your car engine. So America ships all of its own light sweet crude oil to simple refiner. overseas in which takes a lot of oil in Europe and then it sends all of it back here and the Middle East and then it sends it all back here to actually be used and so the energy independence
所以当水力压裂法出现时，页岩油田产出的却是相反的东西。我们从没想过我们能在这里得到轻质甜味原油。结果我们拥有了所有这些轻质甜味原油。所以这是我们真正想要的优质石油，因为酸性原油含有太多的硫，它能制造出非常好的柴油和非常好的沥青。但它很难转化为你放入汽车引擎的石油。所以美国把自己所有的轻质甜味原油运往海外的简单炼油厂，这在欧洲需要大量的石油，然后它又把所有这些运回这里，还有中东，然后它又把所有这些运回这里来实际使用，所以能源独立
was never about whose ground the oil was under there's an entire machine that you really shouldn't say anything about oil like Mitt Romney did if you don't understand like I'm watching him say this in college and everyone's watching and he's like yeah if I'm president going to be oil independent in two years. And it's like, dude, assuming that you had $7 trillion lying around to build these things, because you're, you're, you're not going to be socializing and it's got to be somebody else's money, then where are you going to put them? And they take like seven years to build. What are you talking about? Like the fact that we could be oil independent in two years is just an insane statement. And it proves that you can just say stuff like this,
从来不是关于石油在谁的土地下。有一整套机器，如果你不了解的话，你真的不应该像米特·罗姆尼那样谈论石油。我看着他在大学里说这些，每个人都在看，他说，是的，如果我当选总统，两年内就能实现石油独立。这就像是，伙计，假设你有7万亿美元闲钱来建造这些东西，因为你不会搞社会化，这必须是别人的钱，然后你要把它们放在哪里？它们建造需要七年左右。你在说什么？我们能在两年内实现石油独立的事实简直是一个疯狂的声明。这证明你可以随口说出这种话，
because nobody knows how anything's work. And the world that we live in is so complicated. that we can just say genuinely stupid shit from pretty high levels of power all the time. So again, not just picking on the bureaucracy that I talked about in the psycho history series. This is the whole thing. These things you could Google, you could crack a book. Anyone could pick them up and look at it. And just most of what everyone who's running the world says, I'm not saying that I could do a better job,
因为没人知道任何事情是如何运作的。我们生活的世界太复杂了，以至于我们可以在相当高的权力层面上一直说出真正愚蠢的废话。所以再说一次，不仅仅是针对我在心理历史系列中谈到的官僚机构。这就是整个事情。这些东西你可以谷歌一下，你可以翻翻书。任何人都可以拿起它们看看。大多数统治世界的人所说的话，我不是说我能做得更好，
but I'm just saying that that's how complicated this stuff is. We're speaking in such simplifications about them all the time, whether we want to or not. just like the evidence-based practice in psychology, we are just talking in oversimplifications because they're too complicated. So we can either pick good faith, oversimplifications, or bad faith oversimplifications, but you're still stuck oversimplifying. And the machines that we built, right, they weren't finished like in 1997. We expanded the old ones, we passed them, and then we keep running them, these refineries to make all this oil.
但我只是说这就是这些东西的复杂程度。我们一直在用极其简化的方式谈论它们，无论我们是否愿意。就像心理学中基于证据的实践一样，我们只是在过度简化，因为它们太复杂了。所以我们要么选择善意的过度简化，要么选择恶意的过度简化，但你仍然被困在过度简化中。我们建造的机器，它们在1997年并没有完成。我们扩展了旧的，我们通过了它们，然后我们继续运行它们，这些炼油厂来制造所有这些石油。
And everyone in the industry knows that new refineries are needed. But if you built them, and building them would save the industry. But we don't build them because building one would admit what a new refinery would admit, which means that the capability was allowed to die. The trades are gone. The country that built the last one no longer exists. We probably don't have the ability to build these things. We don't have the infrastructure, even if you had somebody that said, okay, fine.
业内每个人都知道需要新的炼油厂。但如果你建造它们，建造它们会拯救这个行业。但我们不建造它们，因为建造一个新炼油厂就等于承认，这意味着这种能力被允许消亡了。行业消失了。建造最后一个炼油厂的国家已经不存在了。我们可能没有能力建造这些东西。我们没有基础设施，即使你有人说，好吧，没问题。
I don't want to return on an investment. I just want to make a future-proof infrastructure. Like, we're going to spend $7 trillion, building seven, you know, building three or four of these refineries that we need. You probably do not have the domestic knowledge to do it anymore. Christopher Nolan is taking that idea because he's really angry about IMAX projectors, not being able to project his movie and the state. of cinema and sitting with that emotional energy and packaging it in the Odyssey to talk about the death of the Bronze Age. You know, the IMAX projectors we talked about before,
我不想要投资回报。我只是想建立一个面向未来的基础设施。比如，我们要花7万亿美元，建造我们需要的七个，你知道，三四个这样的炼油厂。你可能已经没有国内知识来做这件事了。克里斯托弗·诺兰采用了这个想法，因为他真的很生气，因为IMAX放映机无法放映他的电影，以及电影院的现状，他带着这种情绪能量，并将其包装在《奥德赛》中，谈论青铜时代的终结。你知道，我们之前谈到的IMAX放映机，
like, they're crazy machines. And I talked about this in the first part, but the person who made those machines, the CEO of the company that made those machines said, we don't have blueprints, we don't have knowledge. And even if we did, we don't have the ability to do it. The machine shops that made one little part that was just catching a spindle on the piece of film for the thing that held it down so that it didn't break was a whole alloy component that engineers knew about all the engineers that designed it are dead or they have dementia all of the engineers who could have gotten that information from them when they were younger didn't because the energy industry was going digital and we didn't preserve the knowledge it's lost and even if we had
它们是疯狂的机器。我在第一部分谈到了这一点，但制造这些机器的人，制造这些机器的公司的首席执行官说，我们没有蓝图，我们没有知识。即使我们有，我们也没有能力做到。制造那个小零件的机器车间，那个只是为了抓住胶片轴以固定它而不让它断裂的零件，是一个工程师知道的整个合金组件，所有设计它的工程师都死了，或者他们患有痴呆症，所有本可以在他们年轻时从他们那里获得这些信息的工程师都没有这样做，因为能源行业正在数字化，我们没有保存这些知识，它丢失了，即使我们有
the blueprints and we knew what the alley was and we knew how to manufacture each little tiny part on the machine the supply chain's got. I can't afford to go make somebody build a factory just to make this widget that goes here in this machine. Like it's that he's trying to communicate how complicated this thing and how much the world has changed in really not that much time. This is what the CEO of IMAX was saying when people were livid that they could not see this movie in 70 millimeter. Why are there only 40 theaters in the U.S. that are showing it in 70 millimeter? The McWayton Center in Birmingham, where I live, they used to have a 70 millimeter your machine. When I was a kid, and I went to Colorado when I saw this thing. I went to IMAX
蓝图，我们知道合金是什么，我们知道如何制造机器上的每一个小零件，供应链也断了。我负担不起让别人建一个工厂只是为了制造这个放在机器里的零件。他试图传达这个东西有多复杂，以及世界在这么短的时间内发生了多大的变化。这就是IMAX首席执行官在人们对无法在70毫米胶片上看到这部电影感到愤怒时所说的话。为什么美国只有40家影院在放映70毫米版本？我住的伯明翰的麦克韦顿中心，他们过去有一台70毫米放映机。当我还是个孩子的时候，我去科罗拉多州看到了这个东西。我去了IMAX
in Birmingham. I saw this thing. It was these platters of film that are enormous, you know, to make a platter of film to show like a science movie that's, you know, 20, 30 minutes, you probably spend about five to six, seven thousand dollars to print a three-hour movie like the Odyssey and then ship it. You spend about $35,000. But they're huge. And that was normal when I was 16 when I was 21. They were still around. Then all of a sudden, the world changes really quickly and this stuff is gone. And Christopher Nolan is kind of saying, I'm an artist, I need these tools to make art. And that's why he's reaching these cameras have to have a vacuum built into them to keep the film flat because it is too big to go that fast across the thing. I mean,
在伯明翰。我看到了这个东西。那是巨大的胶片盘，你知道，制作一个胶片盘来放映一部20、30分钟的科学电影，你可能要花大约五到六、七千美元，而打印一部像《奥德赛》这样的三小时电影并运送它，你要花大约35,000美元。但它们太大了。这在我16岁、21岁时很正常。它们依然存在。然后突然之间，世界变化得非常快，这些东西就消失了。克里斯托弗·诺兰有点像是在说，我是一个艺术家，我需要这些工具来创作艺术。这就是为什么他要接触这些摄像机，它们必须内置真空吸尘器来保持胶片平整，因为它太大了，无法以那么快的速度穿过机器。我的意思是，
you see pictures of them. They're giant. Like filming with this thing that he did is stupid. It takes 15, it can keep film in it for about 12 minutes before it runs out and you have to cut. So you can't film for 40 minutes and take the best cuts. You have to change out a canister of film, which takes forever every 12 minutes that you're filming this movie. And I think him reaching for the biggest, most absurd, most affecting extreme tool is him kind of reaching for this lost art in this way that he realizes he couldn't do it in probably five years from now.
你看到它们的照片了。它们是巨大的。像他那样用这个东西拍摄是愚蠢的。它只能容纳大约12分钟的胶片，然后就用完了，你必须剪辑。所以你不能拍摄40分钟然后取最好的片段。你必须更换一个胶片罐，这需要很长时间，每12分钟你拍摄这部电影时都要这样做。我认为他追求最大、最荒谬、最感人、最极端的工具，是他以某种方式追求这种失传的艺术，他意识到五年后他可能就做不到了。
Um, you know, you're filming on a type of film that only 40 theaters in the country can even show people. You can't even show them what you made. And I, I think that he's saying, you know, this culture is getting blinded. You know, you can never observe the same person treated and untreated one timeline each and you cannot observe the same civilization. Same way that I'm talking about with patients, how like once you touch something, it changes. You can't really observe the same civilization both ways any more than you can observe the same person. There's no control group planet. There's no untreated copy of civilization to run beneath this one.
嗯，你知道，你是在一种全国只有40家影院能放映的胶片上拍摄。你甚至无法向人们展示你所制作的东西。而且，我认为他是在说，这种文化正在变得盲目。你知道，你永远无法观察同一个人在治疗和未治疗两种时间线下的情况，你也无法观察同一个文明。就像我谈论病人的方式，一旦你触碰某样东西，它就会改变。你不能再观察同一个文明的两种方式，就像你不能观察同一个人一样。没有对照组星球。没有未受干扰的文明副本来运行在这个文明之下。
You know, like he can't make a business case for it. He can only make an artistic case for this feels right. This feels good. And he's grieving the same thing. I feel this director, even though I have problems sometimes with this director, who's brilliant like in his movies. I'm feeling this director grieving the same thing that I'm talking about in that series. And so it kind of coalesced in my head into this talk. So I think that that is one of the things that Nolan is saying with the movie that I'm also saying and that, you know, some of the
你知道，他无法为此制定商业案例。他只能为这种感觉是对的、感觉很好而制定艺术案例。他也在哀悼我在这系列中谈到的同样的事情。所以我认为这就是诺兰在电影中表达的我也在表达的事情，而且，你知道，一些
infrastructure of our world when we look at what this war for oil when we say that, what does that actually mean, you know, about Iran? I think that these things are all sort of reaching in the same direction. To pull these things back together, I think that Christopher Nolan is reaching for kind of the same argument that I'm reaching for in the psycho history series, but from a different direction, you know, his beef is with these movies and our culture around art. And mine is with the relationship basically of psychotherapy to art. And I think that when you're looking at our relationship to oil, to surplus, to scarcity around, you know, a complex metaphor like war and oil and empire, we're all hitting the same wall where we know what is self-evidently true,
我们世界的基础设施，当我们审视这场石油战争时，当我们这么说时，那到底意味着什么，你知道，关于伊朗？我认为这些事情都在朝着同一个方向努力。要把这些东西重新组合在一起，我认为克里斯托弗·诺兰正在追求我在这部心理历史系列中追求的同样的论点，但方向不同，你知道，他的不满在于这些电影和我们围绕艺术的文化。而我的不满在于心理治疗与艺术的关系。我认为当你审视我们与石油、剩余、稀缺的关系时，你知道，围绕着像战争、石油和帝国这样复杂的隐喻，我们都撞上了同一堵墙，我们知道什么是显而易见的真理，
and the bureaucracy has trapped everyone from doing anything about it. And so our only choice is to maybe get angry for a little while, but then that still doesn't change anything. So we dissociate. We lose knowledge. We forget what we know. you know that all of these you know maybe with more of a business interest but no one has to get to be the biggest director in the entire world with the most power over any studio and this triple super
而官僚机构已经阻止了任何人对此采取任何行动。所以我们唯一的选择可能是生气一会儿，但这仍然改变不了任何事情。所以我们解离。我们失去知识。我们忘记了我们所知道的。你知道，所有这些，也许有更多的商业利益，但诺兰必须成为世界上最伟大的导演，对任何工作室拥有最大的权力，以及这种三重超级
relationship with Warner brothers till he can just come in and say I know that this is right even if the spreadsheet says it's wrong I'm filming on this giant thing it's going to cost tons of money we're not using any CGI we're doing all in camera in facts I'm doing effects we're doing effects, we're doing this insane thing. You know, my industry is, you know, is demanding these double-blind trials for things that are patently silly. And this whole culture is moving into, I don't want to be too morbid, but a decline in the way that we used to make meaning, which doesn't mean that there's not another way to do it.
与华纳兄弟的关系，直到他可以走进来并说，我知道这是对的，即使电子表格说它是错的，我正在用这个巨大的东西拍摄，它会花费大量的钱，我们不使用任何CGI，我们都在摄像机内完成，实际上我正在做特效，我们正在做特效，我们正在做特效，我们正在做这件疯狂的事情。你知道，我的行业正在要求对那些明显愚蠢的事情进行双盲试验。而整个文化正在走向，我不想太病态，但走向我们过去创造意义方式的衰落，这并不意味着没有其他方法可以做到。
But we're clinging to these ways of making meaning and having knowledge and having information that really don't work anymore. Like, we have to have new ones. And going back to oil, oil is the closest thing to free energy that has ever existed. That's why it's so precious to, you know, our ability to have an empire, anyone's ability to have an economy that is growing, that needs to grow bigger every a year, you know, that can't just sort of exist in equilibrium that has to get bigger and bigger every year,
但我们仍然坚持这些创造意义、拥有知识和信息的方式，它们真的不再起作用了。比如，我们必须有新的方式。回到石油，石油是迄今为止最接近免费能源的东西。这就是为什么它对我们拥有帝国的能力、任何人拥有一个每年都需要增长的经济的能力如此珍贵，你知道，它不能只是处于平衡状态，它必须每年变得越来越大，
which is what our entire economic system is built. on millions of years of sunlight, you know, are collected in it, you know, and then it's, it has to become dense enough in some place because a big, you know, carcic dome of salt pushes all the little oil lines together into a big pool when the salt bubbles up and hits the surface. And then we have to make it stable enough to ship everywhere by playing with its chemistry, doing alchemy on it. You know, in every previous empire, it ran on the caloric output of the body, which is why every previous empire ran on some form of coerced flesh, you know, slaves or taxes or professional classes forcing you into a certain job.
这就是我们整个经济体系建立的基础。数百万年的阳光，你知道，被收集在其中，你知道，然后它必须在某个地方变得足够密集，因为一个巨大的、你知道，喀斯特盐丘把所有的小油线推在一起，形成一个大池子，当盐冒泡并到达表面时。然后我们必须通过摆弄它的化学性质，对它进行炼金术，使它足够稳定以运送到各地。你知道，在每一个以前的帝国，它都是靠身体的卡路里输出运行的，这就是为什么每一个以前的帝国都是靠某种形式的强迫肉体运行的，你知道，奴隶或税收或专业阶层强迫你从事某种工作。
This one got run on buried sunlight, which is what makes it kind of an anomaly. It's what makes a lot of the comparisons to ancient empires not work perfectly in America. I mean, one, there's infinite land. it's just bigger container than a lot of these things had. We're just now hitting the limits of some of that. And then two, you have petroleum, which just changes the math. You know, you can try and make a historic equivalent to Rome or Greece or something or the British Empire, but petroleum changes the game quite a bit.
这个帝国是靠埋藏的阳光运行的，这就是它成为一种异常的原因。这就是为什么很多与古代帝国的比较在美国并不完全适用。我的意思是，第一，有无限的土地。它只是比这些东西中的许多容器更大。我们现在才刚刚触及其中一些的极限。然后第二，你有石油，它只是改变了数学。你知道，你可以尝试制造一个与罗马或希腊或英国帝国之类的历史等价物，但石油确实改变了游戏规则。
But oil's not just your fuel, right? Because it's your food. It's fertilizer. It's the actual nitrogen in the actual wheat that we grow and eat, which is why food prices are probably. going to go up a lot if we can't get the straight of hormones to stay open. It's plastic. It's the connective tissue of every, you know, object that you will touch today through plastic and rubber and all the synthetic stuff that we get from it. You know, you brush your teeth with a toothbrush
但石油不仅仅是你的燃料，对吧？因为它是你的食物。它是肥料。它是我们种植和食用的实际小麦中的实际氮，这就是为什么如果我们不能保持激素直通畅通，食品价格可能会上涨很多。它是塑料。它是你今天通过塑料、橡胶和我们从中获得的所有合成材料所接触到的每一个物体的结缔组织。你知道，你用牙刷刷牙
made of oil. There's like all of these things that if we had to make them out of like wood or non-petroleum plastic, things will look very different. It would be very hard to do. But that's why, you know, some scholars sort of call this epoch of human nature, the vampirose. We're just sort of a vampire that is draining this blood of, you know, the living, this old living thing to keep this undead thing moving that we know will break eventually. When the petro subject, you know, drains the blood of the earth, the liquefied ancient dead to keep this synthetic life running that we know is finite. We know is limited. We know that when it's gone, the world will not. be able to look anything like it looks now or civilization will not be able to look anything like
用石油制成的。有所有这些东西，如果我们必须用木头或非石油塑料来制造它们，情况会看起来非常不同。这很难做到。但这就是为什么，你知道，一些学者把人类自然的这个时代称为“吸血鬼时代”。我们只是某种吸血鬼，正在耗尽这种活着的、这种古老生物的血液，以保持这个我们知道最终会崩溃的亡灵事物运行。当石油主体，你知道，耗尽地球的血液，液化的古老死者来保持这种我们知道是有限的合成生命运行时。我们知道它是有限的。我们知道当它消失时，世界将无法看起来像现在这样，或者文明将无法看起来像
it is now. But we're not trying to find an alternative. And we'll never find one that's a perfect one-to-one alternative. We will find another system that is very complicated that will have an alternative to being predominantly dependent on oil. We're not trying. You know, that isn't even really a metaphor. There are, you know, petrochemical traces and human bloodstreams now and microplastics. And, you know, that our relationship to us, this stuff is like fused into us. But it is surplus that's doing that. It's having free energy. It's having free stuff.
它现在这样。但我们并没有试图寻找替代品。我们永远找不到完美的、一对一的替代品。我们将找到另一个非常复杂的系统，它将有一个替代方案，而不是主要依赖石油。我们没有尝试。你知道，这甚至不是一个隐喻。现在人类血液中确实有石油化学痕迹和微塑料。而且，你知道，我们与这些东西的关系就像融合在我们体内一样。但正是剩余在做这件事。正是拥有免费能源。正是拥有免费的东西。
Because when you have scarcity, you have to do long-term planning. You know, when you have surplus, you don't. You know, scarcity forced every household in the past to decide what mattered past tonight. Do I want light or do I want food? And deciding what matters past tonight is the entire operation that we, that is an essential ingredient of meaning making because you're after thinking, you're having to think about what matters after the moment you're in and ultimately after you, which is a skill that we've lost. You know, like a healthy psyche is able to look out after its own death.
因为当你拥有稀缺时，你必须进行长期规划。你知道，当你拥有剩余时，你就不需要了。你知道，稀缺迫使过去的每个家庭决定今晚之后什么才是重要的。我想要光还是想要食物？决定今晚之后什么才是重要的，是我们所做的整个操作，这是意义创造的一个基本要素，因为你在思考之后，你必须思考你所处的时刻之后什么才是重要的，最终是你之后什么才是重要的，这是一种我们已经失去的技能。你知道，一个健康的心理能够在其自身死亡后向外看。
See after the things that just affect it. And an unhealthy psyche cannot do that. It can not conceive of a world where it is not the center of the universe, where it is not order and everything else is not chaos. You know, people used to break ground on cathedrals that they knew that they would never finish. In the medieval period, they're like, yeah, you know, maybe in 200 years this thing will be done. We can't conceive of doing something that takes 20 minutes now. And that's a huge collective shift brought about by our relationship to this energy
看到那些不仅仅影响它的事情。而不健康的心理做不到这一点。它无法构想一个它不是宇宙中心的世界，一个它不是秩序而其他一切不是混乱的世界。你知道，人们过去在他们知道自己永远无法完成的大教堂上破土动工。在中世纪，他们会说，是的，你知道，也许200年后这个东西会完成。我们现在无法构想做一件需要20分钟的事情。这是一个巨大的集体转变，是由我们与这种能源的关系带来的
that is the cheapest form of labor that we've ever found. You know, grandfathers used to plant oak forests for the roof beams. Sorry, the thunder's really loud out there. I don't know if you can hear that, but there's that story that I think it's probably apocryphal or from something. I've heard it from like 20 different people when I was a kid, but people talk about the guy going to Britain, and he says, oh, there's such beautiful wood panels in this library
这是我们发现的最廉价的劳动形式。你知道，祖父们过去常为屋顶梁种植橡树林。抱歉，外面的雷声真的很大。我不知道你们能不能听到，但有一个故事，我想它可能是伪造的或者来自某处。我小时候从大约20个不同的人那里听说过它，但人们谈论那个去英国的人，他说，哦，这个图书馆里有如此美丽的木板
that your grandfather built. It's so sad that there aren't trees big enough to replace these now. If they were ever lost to fire or rot, you know, we would, it's just so sad to think of these being lost. And the guy pulls the curtains forward and said, that is why my great-grandfather planted this grove of trees so that when they rot, I can replace them or whatever. I don't know if it's really true, but I had a lot of like history teachers and people tell me that, you know, either that was what kids today couldn't do and the old people could do
是你祖父建造的。真遗憾，现在没有足够大的树来替换这些了。如果它们因为火灾或腐烂而丢失，你知道，我们会，想到这些丢失真是太遗憾了。那个人拉开窗帘说，这就是我曾祖父种植这片树林的原因，这样当它们腐烂时，我就可以替换它们之类的。我不知道这是否是真的，但我有很多历史老师和人们告诉我，你知道，要么这就是今天孩子做不到而老人能做到的事情
or that that was the difference in the British and the American mindset or whatever. I don't know the origin of it, but. I heard it a lot of times. But, you know, that need to think about a choice, a sacrifice in either direction. Oil ended that choice. It ended that reason to think about sacrifice. But the result wasn't that we created infinite meaning. It was the death of the machine that made meaning when we had that surplus.
或者这就是英国和美国心态的区别之类的。我不知道它的起源，但。我听过很多次。但是，你知道，那种思考一个选择、一个牺牲的需要，无论哪个方向。石油结束了那个选择。它结束了思考牺牲的理由。但结果并不是我们创造了无限的意义。当我们拥有那种剩余时，它是制造意义的机器的死亡。
Because oil made consumption faster than reflection. And it collapsed the distance between wanting, and having. And meaning is a process that runs in that gap. And we paved the gap. You know, a mind that has never has to defer losses. It loses the ability to defer. It loses the ability to not get what it wants at all times, at any time. And this is the mechanism of every addiction that I've ever treated when I treat addiction. It's the space between urge and gratification collapses until the machinery of weighting atrophies and the future stops being real. And the future stops being real to someone. Only the thing that I'm feeling right now is real.
因为石油使消费比反思更快。它缩小了想要和拥有之间的距离。而意义是一个在那个差距中运行的过程。我们铺平了那个差距。你知道，一个从不需要推迟损失的头脑。它失去了推迟的能力。它失去了在任何时候、任何情况下都无法得到它想要的东西的能力。这就是我治疗过的每一种成瘾的机制。冲动和满足之间的空间崩溃了，直到权衡的机制萎缩，未来不再真实。未来对某人来说不再真实。只有我现在感觉到的东西才是真实的。
An oil sped up consumption until we became addicted, unable to invest in meaning or permanence, unable to build for the future, unable to see past our own lifetimes. Stone meant that for a thousand years we had to live in this building that we built out of stone because it took so long to build them like those cathedrals. You know, and then there's glass and it's slightly more, it's still nice, but it's slightly easier to replace. And then there's plastic. And it's strongest on the first day that it's made. It's going to be broken in two weeks.
石油加速了消费，直到我们上瘾，无法投资于意义或持久性，无法为未来建设，无法看到我们自己寿命之外的东西。石头意味着一千年来我们必须住在这个我们用石头建造的建筑里，因为它们建造起来需要很长时间，就像那些大教堂一样。你知道，然后是玻璃，它稍微多一点，它仍然很好，但它稍微容易更换。然后是塑料。它在制造的第一天最坚固。它在两周内就会坏掉。
And that changes the psychology of a culture. We are eating the light. You know, the wealthiest people who have ever lived. And we don't really know what we're living for anymore. Philip Cushman is a psychologist. And, you know, he writes a lot about the empty self and, you know, post-war American stuff. And he says that, like, really post-war America, when you strip it of the traditional
这改变了一种文化的心理。我们正在吃光。你知道，有史以来最富有的人。我们真的不知道我们为什么而活了。菲利普·库什曼是一位心理学家。而且，你知道，他写了很多关于空虚自我和，你知道，战后美国的东西。他说，就像，真正的战后美国，当你剥离它传统的
community, the religious permanence, and the continuity between generations, where somebody knows, this is my generation's project, and we will try our best at it, and then we will hand it off to the next generation to do their project. It will be different than mine. He says, when you get rid of all that, which we sort of have, you're just trying to sort of, like, grow something in this vacuum. And the only way that you can do that is by consuming things. You have to just give people lots of stuff to purchase as a product because they're not really able to do anything that means anything.
社区、宗教持久性和代际连续性时，有人知道，这是我这一代的项目，我们将尽力而为，然后我们将把它交给下一代去做他们的项目。它会和我的一样不同。他说，当你摆脱所有这些时，我们某种程度上已经摆脱了，你只是试图，就像，在真空中种植某种东西。而你唯一能做到这一点的方法就是消费东西。你必须给人们很多东西去购买作为产品，因为他们真的无法做任何有意义的事情。
And so, well, my preference must be the ultimate, you know, meaning. You know, goods and experiences and therapy. Therapy as a product is a bad thing. You know, the consuming, the act of consumption builds this self that lasts about as long as the purpose. which is an addiction. You know, petroleum is this ideal operating system for that empty cell. And probably some of the finance capital that goes along with petroleum. You know, it makes the consuming feel fast enough and cheap enough that the vacuum never has to be felt for very long, the vacuum of not having meaning. We never have to sit with it long enough to say,
所以，好吧，我的偏好必须是最终的，你知道，意义。你知道，商品、体验和治疗。治疗作为一种产品是一件坏事。你知道，消费，消费的行为构建了这个持续时间大约和目的一样长的自我，这是一种成瘾。你知道，石油是那个空虚自我的理想操作系统。可能还有一些与石油相伴的金融资本。你知道，它使消费感觉足够快、足够便宜，以至于真空永远不需要被感觉到太久，那种没有意义的真空。我们从来不需要坐下来足够长的时间来说，
what do we want to change? Because we can go out and get quick fixes for meaning so fast. you know, Lauren Bellerant, she has this idea, cruel optimism. She says that, you know, being attached to the exact thing that is blocking or flourishing is this interesting, you know, way of thinking about addiction. You know, and energy scholars say crude optimism, that we hold on to oil as this guarantee of this good life while foreclosing the future of the good life, But while getting rid of the future, the good life was supposed to happen in. We know what happens to the American mind when the fuel gets pinched because, you know, it's already happened before.
我们想改变什么？因为我们可以如此迅速地获得意义的快速修复。你知道，劳伦·贝兰特，她有这个想法，残酷的乐观主义。她说，你知道，依恋于阻碍我们繁荣的正是那个东西，这是思考成瘾的一种有趣的方式。你知道，能源学者说残酷的乐观主义，我们坚持石油作为这种美好生活的保证，同时取消了美好生活的未来，但在取消未来的同时，美好生活本应发生。我们知道当燃料被挤压时美国人的头脑会发生什么，因为，你知道，它以前发生过。
Like in 73, the oil embargo where the Arab producers shut the tap over, you know, the Qapur war. And the first time since the frontier closed, the American material world said no to this new relationship that we had. consumption came down. There's gas lines around the block. And like the thing that made, if you didn't live through it, which I didn't live through it, but if you, if you're wondering what history is like, somebody telling you like, yeah, we had to wait in line to get gas, that was not what made the oil embargo scary. It made every project in America because they all were dependent on oil be tenuous. It made everybody wonder if everything about the economy could and would continue to work like it ever always had. And then the, you know,
就像在73年，阿拉伯生产商因为赎罪日战争关闭了石油禁运。自边境关闭以来，美国物质世界第一次对我们拥有的这种新关系说了不。消费下降了。街区周围有加油站排队。而且，你知道，那件事，如果你没有经历过它，我没有经历过它，但如果你，如果你想知道历史是什么样的，有人告诉你，是的，我们不得不排队加油，那并不是让石油禁运变得可怕的原因。它使美国的每一个项目，因为它们都依赖石油，变得脆弱。它让每个人都怀疑经济的一切是否能够并且将会像它一直以来那样继续运作。然后，你知道，
William Barger went away and we forgot that we ever felt like that, but we did feel that way. And there's a whole generation where people weren't allowed to have stuff. They weren't allowed to consume as much. And people are very bad at, you know, well, not bad at it, like it's a bad thing, but people are very resilient. They're bad at saying, I don't have personal power. So what people did is they went inward and you got all of these kind of spiritual revolution stuff. You get Star Wars, you get introspection, and some of it's silly in navel gazing.
威廉·巴格消失了，我们忘记了我们曾经有过那种感觉，但我们确实有过那种感觉。有一整代人，人们不被允许拥有东西。他们不被允许消费那么多。人们非常不擅长，你知道，嗯，不是不擅长，好像这是一件坏事，但人们非常有韧性。他们不擅长说，我没有个人权力。所以人们所做的是他们向内看，你得到了所有这些精神革命之类的东西。你得到了《星球大战》，你得到了内省，其中一些是愚蠢的，是自我沉迷。
But, you know, the 70s makes sense in that light. It was this human potential movement and psychotherapy explode. You know, those, the EST simulars that I talked about, like the gurus and cults and Jonestown and astrology, and like all of that was a result of people not being able to buy the things that they had been buying in the 50s and the 60s at that pace or the same type of stuff. things did get slightly more permanent, like in the way that they were designed for a minute, and then that immediately went away in the 80s and everything became disposable again. But, you know, after the embargo, Congress ordered the strategic petroleum reserve, you know,
但是，你知道，70年代在那种光线下是有意义的。那是人类潜能运动和心理治疗的爆发。你知道，那些，我谈到的EST模拟器，比如大师和邪教，琼斯镇和占星术，以及所有这些都是人们无法以50年代和60年代那种速度或同样类型的东西购买他们一直在购买的东西的结果。事情确实稍微变得更持久了一些，就像它们被设计的方式一样，持续了一分钟，然后这在80年代立即消失了，一切又变得可以随意丢弃了。但是，你知道，禁运后，国会下令建立战略石油储备，你知道，
and they said we're going to have this, you know, giant like pile, basically, of oil so that if there's ever a problem again, you know, we'll be able to be a little bit more resilient. in. And what's interesting is the way that you store oil like that is salt. When oil forms, there's like a giant dome of salt that pushes up. And like oil is just in these like thin little layers, like pieces of paper. Or like imagine if you have like a, I don't know, like a really long tube full of, you know, a little sandwich baggy, you know, full of a tiny bit of water. And there's like no water in it, but if you get your finger and you squish the sandwich bag, you can push all the water down to one of the corners. So these oil pockets that get mined or tapped or whatever,
他们说我们将拥有这个，你知道，巨大的，基本上是石油堆，这样如果再次出现问题，你知道，我们将能够更有韧性。而且有趣的是，你储存石油的方式是盐。当石油形成时，有一个巨大的盐丘向上推。而且，你知道，石油只是在这些薄薄的小层里，像纸片一样。或者想象如果你有一个，我不知道，像一个装满，你知道，一点点水的长管，你知道，一个小三明治袋。里面几乎没有水，但如果你用手指挤压三明治袋，你可以把所有的水推到其中一个角落。所以这些被开采或利用的油袋，或者无论什么，
I don't know what you call it pumped out, they're right next to these giant like pillars of salt. They come rising up from the deep earth because the salt is the thing that pushes the little sleeves of oil together to make those pockets. So it's convenient that they're right close to each other. because you need the giant salt pocket in order to store the oil that you're pumping out of the ground. It'd be really expensive to build like a tank big enough to hold all this stuff. So outside of a refinery, we don't. Like a lot of time, we get these salt domes and we hollow them out. And there's an interesting kind of political story in Timothy Mitchell's book,
我不知道你们管这叫什么，抽出来，它们就在这些巨大的盐柱旁边。它们从深层地壳中升起，因为盐分正是将那些小油层挤压在一起形成油囊的东西。所以它们靠得这么近很方便，因为你需要巨大的盐囊来储存你从地下抽出来的石油。建造一个足够大的储油罐会非常昂贵，所以在炼油厂之外，我们不会这样做。很多时候，我们利用这些盐丘并将它们掏空。蒂莫西·米切尔（Timothy Mitchell）的书里有一个有趣的政治故事，
Carbon Democracy. And he says that coal accidentally built mass democracy. because he says that coal is like really heavy and concentrated and so it moves through choke points. So you have like, you know, the railhead and the place where it's being mined and then you have the docks and then you have the minute those choke points. And those are all choke points where like any group, if they have enough power can just be like, no, the coal does not go past here. And when that stops, it shuts the whole system down. So everybody involved in the process, like from the minor to, you know, the dock. worker to the driver that has to, you know, get the thing to your house. In that system,
《碳民主》（Carbon Democracy）。他说，煤炭意外地建立了大众民主。因为他说煤炭非常沉重且集中，所以它通过瓶颈运输。所以你有，你知道，铁路终点站、开采地，然后是码头，然后你有那些瓶颈。这些都是瓶颈，任何群体如果拥有足够的力量，就可以说，不，煤炭不能从这里通过。当它停止时，整个系统就会瘫痪。所以参与这个过程的每个人，从矿工到，你知道，码头工人，再到必须把东西送到你家的司机。在那个系统中，
all of that labor has a lot of power because if they stop doing stuff, then your whole system stops. But the switch to oil appealed to people running things a lot more than coal because oil flows around workers. You can just build a pipeline. You don't really need all these people touching it. And so the rich person just gets to keep all the power to keep it flowing. even if people don't like the way the economy is working, they can't really stop it. And so the incentives are sort of sitting in the physics that oil is liquid and it's lighter and it's denser energetically than coal. You don't need as much labor. And so Mitchell says that, you know, before the 1930s, the word economy meant careful management.
所有的劳动力都拥有很大的权力，因为如果他们停止工作，整个系统就会停止。但转向石油对掌权者来说比煤炭更有吸引力，因为石油可以在工人周围流动。你只需要铺设一条管道。你并不真正需要所有这些人去接触它。因此，富人可以保持所有的权力来维持它的流动。即使人们不喜欢经济运作的方式，他们也无法真正阻止它。所以激励机制某种程度上存在于物理学中，即石油是液体，而且比煤炭更轻、能量密度更高。你不需要那么多的劳动力。所以米切尔说，你知道，在20世纪30年代之前，“经济”这个词意味着审慎的管理。
It meant frugality. It meant, you know, husbanding what you had. And in the oil age, it was redefined as this thing that was this autonomous sphere, of infinite existential growth. And that is this myth. And I'm not saying that it isn't real. I'm calling it a myth because it is the operating logic of the system that we are running the world on right now in a way that may or may not be true. There's this idea of exponential growth that is this fantasy that only pencils out, you know, while cheap petroleum pours in without limit.
它意味着节俭。它意味着，你知道，珍惜你所拥有的。而在石油时代，它被重新定义为一种自主的、无限存在增长的领域。这就是一个神话。我并不是说它不是真实的。我称之为神话，是因为它是我们目前运行世界所依据的操作逻辑，这可能是真的，也可能不是。有一种指数增长的观念，这是一种幻想，你知道，只有在廉价石油无限制涌入的情况下才能成立。
you know, democracy got downgraded to match this practice of collective struggle to this technocratic management of the economy and citizens got re-engineered as consumers whose main civic duty is to keep the fuel and the money moving. And so under the old economy, you are all sort of touching as labor, the movement and the process of getting coal from one place to the next. But in the new economy, you're not. Your job is to be buying things and consuming them because that is what makes you valuable is that you are not ever going to be self-sufficient. You're not ever going to be you're not ever going to have enough. You have to be buying all the time. And so again, to wrap things up, you know, the question that nobody on the news is asking, are we going into a dark age?
你知道，民主被降级以适应这种集体斗争的实践，变成了对经济的技术官僚管理，而公民被重新设计为消费者，其主要公民义务是保持燃料和资金的流动。因此，在旧经济下，作为劳动力，你们都在某种程度上接触着将煤炭从一地运往另一地的过程。但在新经济中，你不是。你的工作是购买和消费，因为这才是让你有价值的原因，即你永远不会自给自足。你永远不会拥有足够的东西。你必须一直购买。所以再次总结一下，你知道，新闻里没有人问的问题是，我们正在进入一个黑暗时代吗？
Elijah Milgram, I've mentioned it a long time ago, not for a while, but the great endarkenedment. He has this idea that the enlightenment, he has this idea that the enlightenment, when it happens, and science is like coming back, you know, into mainstream culture and changing technology and changing art and changing society. He says, the enlightenment ran on a promise that you could use your own understanding. And the fine print was that one person, person's understanding could at least in principle, you know, check this argument. One person's like understanding could, could see how the whole system worked through science. That was the
以利亚·米尔格拉姆（Elijah Milgram），我很久以前提到过，有一段时间没提了，关于“大黑暗化”（the great endarkenedment）。他有一个观点，即启蒙运动，当它发生时，科学正在回归主流文化，改变技术、艺术和社会。他说，启蒙运动建立在一个承诺之上，即你可以运用你自己的理解力。而细则则是，一个人的理解力至少在原则上可以，你知道，检验这个论点。一个人的理解力可以通过科学看到整个系统是如何运作的。这就是
gift that science brought us when we got rid of some of the religious superstition and the Enlightenment and moved more to a scientific paradigm. You know, the Western history scholars would tell you. But what he says is that we're hyper-special. now. So every specialty is speaking its own dialect and nobody can audit the reasoning in the lab next door. Like, I'm telling psychotherapist something about the way the psychotherapy works that they may not know and that is their profession because they're not a researcher. They're clinical. Even within the silo, there are silos. And because all of this information is so cut up and nobody has access to all of it, there's too much fine print.
科学带给我们的礼物，当我们摆脱了一些宗教迷信和启蒙运动，转向更科学的范式时。你知道，西方历史学者会告诉你。但他所说的是，我们现在是超级专业化的。所以每个专业都在说自己的方言，没有人能审计隔壁实验室的推理。比如，我正在告诉心理治疗师一些关于心理治疗运作方式的事情，他们可能不知道，而那是他们的专业，因为他们不是研究人员。他们是临床医生。即使在筒仓内，也有筒仓。而且因为所有这些信息都被切碎了，没有人能接触到全部，细则太多了。
And so all the knowledge has to just be this trust in an institution. At the exact moment that our institutions are telling us, don't trust them. Don't trust us. Directly or indirectly, most people are getting that message. And so like the FDA hearing from that last episode, this is the beginning of a dark age where people don't have enough information to understand how anything works.
所以所有的知识都必须是对机构的信任。就在我们的机构告诉我们，不要信任他们，不要信任我们的时候。直接或间接地，大多数人都在接收这个信息。所以就像上一集听到的FDA听证会一样，这是一个黑暗时代的开始，人们没有足够的信息来理解任何事情是如何运作的。
Even the people that are very smart and very educated, because they only understand how one part of the elephant that they are touching. They only understand that part. And the antidote to that would just be to trust the system. But the system is also going away or revealing itself to not really have all of the answers. And so what Elijah Milgram is saying is that knowledge is going to splinter now into dialects that nobody can speak most of. maybe more than one of. And there will be capabilities that it just stops being anyone's job to keep.
即使是非常聪明和受过良好教育的人，因为他们只理解他们所接触的大象的一部分。他们只理解那一部分。而解决这个问题的解药就是信任系统。但系统也在消失，或者显露出它并没有真正拥有所有的答案。所以以利亚·米尔格拉姆所说的是，知识现在将分裂成没有人能说大多数方言的碎片，也许不止一种。而且将会有一些能力，不再是任何人的工作去维护它们。
Like how to make an IMAX, moving, something that was made, you know, rolling off assembly lines when I was a kid. Now, if we turned millions of dollars to it, we could not make it happen again.
比如如何制造IMAX，移动的东西，我小时候流水线上生产的东西。现在，如果我们投入数百万美元，我们也无法让它再次发生。
And, you know, people are not going to realize that this is happening for a while. The whole society stays lit and there's, you know, every screen is still glowing. But there's no shared light where, we can really check if there is like a,
而且，你知道，人们在一段时间内不会意识到正在发生什么。整个社会依然灯火通明，你知道，每个屏幕都在发光。但没有共同的光，我们可以真正检查是否有一个，
maybe losing this metaphor, but like there's not a way that we can see if we're all sort of reading the same text anymore. Like people will just get an LLM to explain something to them and then think that they understand it. Maybe they have some kind of understanding of it. But there's less of like a source of this information that is centralized. The silos will get even smaller.
也许这个比喻用得不好，但就像我们无法再看到我们是否都在阅读同一文本一样。人们只会找一个大语言模型（LLM）来向他们解释某事，然后认为他们理解了。也许他们确实对它有某种理解。但这种信息的来源不再集中。筒仓会变得更小。
And so the Dark Age doesn't just, happen in one night and it doesn't really feel like a night you know it arrives like a long afternoon that nobody really names and the silence is all around you and you're asking whether the empire is ending at the same time that there's all these things on the news and the empire's defenses exist and it's doing this performance that's saying that it isn't and so you never really get a clear answer And so, like, if I don't think it's an easy or a simple question, like, are you going into basically another dark age? But you do see knowledge splintering and you see it going into different dialects that nobody seems to be speaking the same of anymore. And you see the major infrastructure capabilities for society becoming something that it seems like everyone says, well, that's not my job to keep up.
所以黑暗时代不会在一夜之间发生，它感觉也不像是一个夜晚，你知道，它像一个漫长的下午一样到来，没有人真正给它命名，沉默就在你周围，你问帝国是否正在终结，同时新闻里有所有这些事情，帝国的防御存在，它在进行这种表演，说它没有终结，所以你永远得不到明确的答案。所以，如果我不认为这是一个简单的问题，比如，你是否正在进入另一个黑暗时代？但你确实看到知识在分裂，你看到它进入了不同的方言，似乎没有人再说同一种语言了。而且你看到社会的主要基础设施能力似乎变成了每个人都说，“维护它不是我的工作”。
And that's a scary thing. We've not really had this little light in a long time, even though we have a whole lot of food. And, you know, like the dark age doesn't really just happen overnight. It arrives over a really long period where people are wondering and there's a lot of silence, what is happening. And there's a lot of performativity happening culturally. You know, but going back to the. beginning of this series. Like a number is a description of a thing. It is not a thing. You can run a company by a number, but that doesn't mean that the company is good just because
这是一件可怕的事情。我们已经很久没有这种微光了，尽管我们有很多食物。而且，你知道，黑暗时代并不会在一夜之间发生。它在很长一段时间内到来，人们在怀疑，周围有很多沉默，发生了什么。文化上有很多表演性。你知道，回到这个系列的开头。数字是对事物的描述。它不是事物本身。你可以通过数字来经营一家公司，但这并不意味着公司好，仅仅因为
the number is good. You can run a society based on a number. You can run therapy based on a number. That doesn't mean that those things are good, even though that the number is good, because the number is a description, and you may be describing something extremely poorly. You know, the Bronze Age left us, the oldest version of a description of people looking back at a time that they sort of remember that they came from and they wanted to hold on to, but they didn't know how to literally, how to historically talk about it anymore. And the Odyssey is them trying to do that when they don't even really have clay tablets. They only have oral tradition. It's a mythology about their past that is kind of sort of halfway true, just like Nolan's film, when it comes to theme and tone
数字很好。你可以基于数字来经营一个社会。你可以基于数字来经营治疗。这并不意味着这些事情是好的，尽管数字是好的，因为数字是描述，而你可能描述得非常糟糕。你知道，青铜时代留给我们的是，人们回顾他们记忆中来自的时代的最古老的描述版本，他们想坚持下去，但他们不知道如何从字面上、从历史上谈论它了。而《奥德赛》是他们试图这样做，当他们甚至没有泥板时。他们只有口头传统。这是一个关于他们过去的神话，某种程度上是半真半假的，就像诺兰的电影在主题、基调
and soul, but not really in the details. It doesn't look like the trading empire that got wiped out by the Mycenaeans to stop this choke point during a drought. And those details didn't have a giant wooden horse. But the story is largely a true story of a people trying to remember in the best way that they knew how and preserve in the best way that they knew how the parts of themselves that they wanted to remember. You know, my own field is still inside of all of these things. It's still connected to them. A lot of therapy right now treats, you know, dread and depression and the compulsive consuming going on as these individual malfunctions as something that like you need to fix as an individual and maybe you have some responsibility. But these are connections.
和灵魂方面一样，但在细节上并非如此。它看起来不像那个在干旱期间为了阻止这个瓶颈而被迈锡尼人消灭的贸易帝国。那些细节里没有巨大的木马。但这个故事在很大程度上是一个真实的故事，讲述了一群人试图以他们所知的最好方式去记忆，并以他们所知的最好方式去保存他们想要记住的自己的部分。你知道，我自己的领域仍然在所有这些事情之中。它仍然与它们相连。现在很多治疗方法将，你知道，恐惧、抑郁和强迫性消费视为个人的功能障碍，视为你需要作为个人去修复的东西，也许你负有一些责任。但这些都是联系。
to a larger narrative, a larger thing that we have to confront. If we're going to make meaning, even if we can't change it, I do think that we have to notice it to have clarity about where all this stuff's coming from. We adjust people until they can keep communicating and then we call that treatment. I'm sorry, not communicating, commuting. If you can just keep going to work, if you can keep working and functioning in this thing, you're well. My argument is, You also should have some clarity over how this thing works and how to have more control over your life, even if that clarity brings you temporarily pain, even if it takes away a kind of naivety that you used to have. Even if it takes away a numbness that you used to have, it is your responsibility to confront the dissociation that everybody is feeling enough to react to this world with clarity.
与一个更大的叙事、一个我们必须面对的更大的事物相连。如果我们想要创造意义，即使我们无法改变它，我确实认为我们必须注意到它，才能清楚这一切是从哪里来的。我们调整人们直到他们能继续交流，然后我们称之为治疗。抱歉，不是交流，是通勤。如果你能继续去上班，如果你能继续工作并在这种事物中运作，你就健康了。我的论点是，你也应该对这个东西是如何运作的以及如何对你的生活有更多的控制权有清晰的认识，即使这种清晰暂时给你带来痛苦，即使它带走了你曾经拥有的某种天真。即使它带走了你曾经拥有的麻木感，你有责任面对每个人都感受到的疏离感，足以以清晰的态度去应对这个世界。
I think that that is part of what psychology is, and maybe some people would disagree with me. But sometimes just noticing and seeing and hearing these things that you can't see, unsee and you can't unhear, is the mechanism of action. And I don't think my profession can admit that because its whole apparatus is still built on subtracting everything other than the one thing that created change.
我认为这是心理学的一部分，也许有些人会不同意我。但有时仅仅是注意到、看到和听到这些你无法“未见”和“未听”的事情，就是作用机制。我不认为我的职业能承认这一点，因为它的整个装置仍然建立在减去除了创造改变的那一件事之外的所有东西上。
But sometimes it's that simple. Before you have the diagnosis, when you say, I feel this way, me saying and noticing that already has started to change how it is that I feel. And when I say I feel this way because, or I feel this way for a long time, I didn't notice how long I felt this way. That is the beginning of a change process that can't be studied because it can't be undone. And we can't control for before that awareness was brought up because we can't measure what I was feeling before I said that I was feeling that way. I'm like naming the defense mechanism is sometimes the treatment.
但有时就是这么简单。在你得到诊断之前，当你对自己说，“我有这种感觉”，我对此的肯定和注意已经开始改变我的感受了。当我对自己说“我有这种感觉是因为……”或者“我感觉这种方式很久了，我没注意到我感觉这种方式有多久了”。这就是改变过程的开始，它无法被研究，因为它无法被撤销。而且我们无法控制这种意识被唤起之前的情况，因为我们无法衡量我在说出那种感觉之前感受到了什么。我像是在命名防御机制，有时这就是治疗。
And, you know, the culture can't always admit that because its defenses exist to prevent its authority from coming into question. But a lot of authority is being called into question now. So, you know, the cure for maybe the micro and the macro is the same. I think we should demythologize a lot of the mythology that we have right now. And I'm a Jungian therapist. I like mythology. But there's a lot of people who think that the reason that you play with mythology is a Jungian therapist is so that you can like, I don't know, attain enlightenment from studying myths.
而且，你知道，文化并不总是能承认这一点，因为它的防御机制存在是为了防止其权威受到质疑。但现在很多权威正在受到质疑。所以，你知道，微观和宏观的治愈方法可能是一样的。我认为我们应该对我们现在拥有的很多神话进行去神话化。我是一名荣格心理治疗师。我喜欢神话。但有很多人认为，作为荣格心理治疗师玩弄神话的原因是，你可以，我不知道，通过研究神话获得启蒙。
No, it's so that you recognize these stories as ultimately your own and ultimately kind of serious, silly and ultimately kind of malleable and able to be deconstructed and able to be reconstructed. Because, yeah, this stuff's going on. and there's one person, you know, in the therapy room. But the empire is made out of people. And, you know, all of these people, it takes to make a story as complicated as the things that I'm describing here.
不，这是为了让你认识到这些故事最终是你自己的，最终是严肃的、愚蠢的，最终是可塑的，能够被解构和重构的。因为，是的，这些事情正在发生，而且治疗室里只有一个人。但帝国是由人组成的。而且，你知道，所有这些人，需要创造一个像我在这里描述的那样复杂的故事。
And when you tell a story, well, I'll end with this. Another way of saying that, that is maybe a clearer way of saying it, is that you are part of a story and you are telling yourself a story, whether or not you know it. One of the freedoms that we have as a culture is to see these stories for what they are, inside and outside. We don't always really get to have a lot of change
当你讲一个故事时，好吧，我以此结束。另一种说法，也许更清晰的说法是，你是故事的一部分，你正在给自己讲一个故事，无论你是否知道。作为一种文化，我们拥有的自由之一就是看清这些故事的本质，无论是在内部还是外部。我们并不总是能有很多改变
over how they end. The freedom isn't seeing them for what they are. And even if that doesn't change anything material, I think that there is a freedom in that helps change something, that even if we can't measure it, is very important and is very real. Many years have passed in this river town.
关于它们如何结束。自由在于看清它们的本质。即使这不能改变任何物质上的东西，我认为这种自由有助于改变某些东西，即使我们无法衡量它，它也是非常重要且非常真实的。在这个河畔小镇，许多年过去了。
I sail through many traps. I keep a stock of weapons should society collapse. I keep a stock of ammo, one of oil and one of gold. Keep a place for Mary Ann, soon she will come home. I know I'm a long shot. Us have you got Get taker Many tickets have I torn
我穿过许多陷阱。我储备了武器以防社会崩溃。我储备了弹药，一份石油和一份黄金。为玛丽·安留个位置，她很快就会回家。我知道我机会渺茫。我们有你得到的拿走者，我撕碎了多少张票
We will float above the storm There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将漂浮在风暴之上。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。